the following is a conversation with
stephen wolfram his third time on the
podcast he's a computer scientist
mathematician theoretical physicist and
the founder of wolfram research a
company behind mathematica wolf from
alpha wolfram language and the new
wolfram physics project
this conversation is a wild technical
rollercoaster ride through topics of
complexity mathematics physics computing
and consciousness i think this is what
this podcast is becoming a wild ride
some episodes are about physics some
about robots some are about war and
power some are about the human condition
and our search for meaning and some are
just what the comedian tim dillon calls
fun
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out the sponsors
in the description and now here's my
conversation with steven wolfram
almost 20 years ago you published a new
kind of science where you presented a
study of complexity and an approach for
modeling of complex systems so
let us return again to the core idea of
complexity
what
is
complexity i don't know i think that's
not the most interesting question it's
like
you know if you ask a biologist what is
life yeah that's not the question they
care the most about
what i was interested in is
how does
something that we would usually identify
as complexity arise in nature and i got
interested in that question like 50
years ago which is really embarrassingly
a long time ago
and you know i i was uh you know how
does snowflakes get to have complicated
forms how do galaxies get to have
complicated shapes how does you know how
do living systems get produced things
like that and the question is what's the
sort of underlying scientific basis for
those kinds of things
and the thing that i was at first very
surprised by because i've been doing
physics and particle physics and fancy
mathematical physics and so on and it's
like i know all this fancy stuff i
should be able to solve this sort of
basic science question and i couldn't
this was like early maybe
1980-ish time frame and it's like okay
what can one do to understand the sort
of basic secret that nature seems to
have because it seems like nature you
look around in the natural world it's
full of incredibly complicated forms you
look at
sort of most engineered kinds of things
for instance they tend to be you know
we've got sort of circles and
lines and things like this the question
is what secret does nature have that
lets it make all this complexity that we
in doing engineering for example don't
naturally seem to have and so that was
the kind of the thing that i got
interested in and then the question was
you know could i understand that with
things like mathematical physics well
didn't work very well so then i got to
thinking about okay is there some other
way to try to understand this and then
the question was if you're going to look
at some system in nature how do you make
a model for that system for what that
system does so you know a model is some
abstract representation of the system
some formal representation system what
are what is the raw material that you
can make that model out of and so what i
realized was well actually programs are
really good source of raw material for
making models of things and you know in
terms of my personal history the to me
that seemed really obvious and the
reason it seemed really obvious is
because i just spent several years
building this big piece of software that
was sort of a predecessor to mathematica
and multiple language thing called smp
symbolic manipulation program which was
something that had this idea of starting
from just these computational primitives
and building up everything one had to
build up and so kind of the notion of
well let's just try and make models by
starting from computational primitives
and seeing what we can build up that
seemed like a totally obvious thing to
do
in uh in retrospect it might not have
been externally quite so obvious but it
was obvious to me at the time given the
path that i happened to have been on so
you know so that got me into this
question of let's use programs to model
what happens in nature
and the question then is well what kind
of programs and you know we're used to
programs that you write for some
particular purpose it's a big long piece
of code and it does some specific thing
but what i got interested in was okay if
you just go out into the sort of
computational universe of possible
programs you say
take the simplest program you can
imagine what does it do
and so i started studying these things
called cellular automata um actually i
didn't know at first they were called
cellular automata but i found that out
subsequently but it's just a line of
cells you know each one is black or
white and it's just some rule that says
the color of the cell is determined by
the color that it had on the previous
step and it's two neighbors on the
previous step and i had initially
thought
that's you know sufficiently simple
setup it's not going to do anything
interesting it's always going to be
simple no complexity simple rule simple
behavior okay but then i actually ran
the computer experiment which was pretty
easy to do um i mean it probably took a
few hours um originally and um the and
the results were not what i'd expected
at all now needless to say in the way
that science actually works the results
that i got a lot of unexpected things
which i thought were really interesting
but the really strongest results which
was already right there in the printouts
i made i didn't really understand for a
couple more years
so it was it was not you know the
compressed version of the story is
you run the experiment and you
immediately see what's going on but i
wasn't smart enough to to do that so to
speak
but the big the big thing is
even with very simple rules of that type
sort of the minimal
tiniest program sort of the the the one
line program or something it's possible
to get very complicated behavior my
favorite example is this thing called
rule 30 which is a particular cellular
automaton rule you just started off from
one black cell and it makes this really
complicated pattern
and so that for me was sort of a
critical discovery
that then kind of said playing back onto
you know how does nature make complexity
i sort of realized that might be how it
does it that might be kind of the secret
that it's using
is that in this kind of computational
universe of possible programs
it's actually pretty easy to get
programs where even though the program
is simple the behavior when you run the
program is not simple at all
and that was so for me that was the the
kind of the the story of kind of how
that that was sort of the the indication
that one had got an idea of what the
sort of secret that nature uses to make
complexity and that complexity how
complexity can be made in other places
now if you say what is complexity you
know it's it's
complexity is it's not easy to tell
what's going on that's the informal
version of what is complexity but there
is something going on but there's a rule
to know what right well no the rules can
generate just randomness
well that that's not obvious
in other words that's not how it is not
obvious at all and it wasn't what i
expected it's not what people's
intuition had been and has been for you
know for a long time that is one might
think you have a rule
you can tell
there's a rule behind it i mean it's
just like you know the early you know
robots and science fiction movies right
you can tell it's a robot because it
does simple things
right turns out that isn't actually the
right story
but it's not obvious that isn't the
right story because people assume simple
rules simple behavior
and that the sort of the key discovery
about the computational universe is that
isn't true and that discovery goes very
deep and relates to all kinds of things
that i've spent years and years studying
but um you know that that in the end the
sort of the the what is complexity is
well you can't easily tell what it's
going to do you could just run the rule
and see what happens but you can't just
say oh you know show me the rule great
and now i know what's going to happen
and you know the key phenomenon around
that is this thing i call computational
irreducibility this fact that in
something like rule 30 you might say
well what's it going to do after a
million steps
well you can run it for a million steps
and just do what it does to find out
but you can't compress that you can't
reduce that and say i'm going to be able
to jump ahead and say this is what it's
going to do after a million steps but i
don't have to go through anything like
that computational effort by the way has
anybody succeeded at that you had a
challenge a competition right for
predicting the middle column of rule 30
and indeed anybody
a number of people have sent things in
and and sort of people are picking away
at it but it's hard i mean it's it's uh
i've been i've been actually uh even
proving that the center column of rule
30 doesn't repeat
that's something i think might be doable
okay mathematically proving yes and so
that's analogous to
a similar kind of things like the digits
of pi which are also generated in this
very deterministic way
and so a question is how random are the
digits of pi for example does every
first of all do the digits of pi ever
repeat or we know they don't because it
was proved in the 1800s that pi is not a
rational number so that means only
rational numbers have digit sequences
that repeat so we know the digits of pi
don't repeat so now the question is does
you know 0 1 2 3 or whatever do all the
digits base 10 or base 2 or however you
work it out do they all occur with equal
frequency
nobody knows
that's far away from what can be
understood mathematically at this point
and that's that's kind of uh but i'm i'm
even looking for step one which is
prove that the the the center column
doesn't repeat and then prove other
things about it like equidistribution of
of uh equal numbers of zeros and ones
and those are things which i you know i
kind of set up this little little prize
thing because i thought those were not
not too out of range those are things
which are within
you know
a modest amount of time it's conceivable
that those could be done they're not
they're not far away from what current
mathematics might allow they'll require
a bunch of cleverness and hopefully some
interesting new ideas that you know will
be useful other places
but you started in 1980 with this idea
before i think you realized
you know this idea of programs
you thought that there might be some
kind of thermodynamic like randomness
and then complexity comes from a clever
filter
that uh you kind of like i don't know
spaghetti or something you you you
filter the randomness and outcomes
complexity which is an interesting
intuition i mean
how do we know that's not actually
what's happening so just because you
were then able to develop
look you don't need this like incredible
randomness you can just have very simple
predictable initial conditions and
predictable rules and then from that
emergency complexity
still there might be some systems where
it's uh filtering randomness and the
inputs well the point is
when you have quotes randomised in the
input that means there's all kinds of
information in the input yeah and in a
sense what you get out will be maybe
just something close to what you put in
like people are very in dynamical
systems theory sort of big area
mathematics that developed
from the early 1900s and and really got
big in the 1980s you know an example of
what people study there a lot and it's
popular version is chaos theory um an
example what people study a lot is the
shift map which is basically taking 2x
mod 1 to the fractional part of 2x which
is basically just taking digits in
binary and shifting them to the left so
at every step you get to see if you say
how big is this number that i got out
well the most important digit in that
number is whatever ended up at the at
the left-hand end but now if you start
off from an arbitrary random number
which is quotes randomly chosen so all
its digits are random then when you run
that sort of chaos theory shift map all
that you get out is just whatever you
put in you just get to see what you what
it's not obvious that you would excavate
all of those digits and if you're for
example making a theory i don't know
fluid mechanics for example if there was
that phenomenon in fluid mechanics then
the equations of fluid mechanics can't
be right because what that would be
saying is the equations of that that it
matters to the fluid what happens in the
fluid at the level of the you know
millionth digit of the initial
conditions which is far below the point
at which you're hitting kind of sizes of
molecules and things like that so it's
kind of almost explaining
if that phenomenon is an important thing
it's kind of telling you that the you
know fluid dynamics which describes
fluids as continuous media and so on
isn't isn't really right but so you know
so this idea that you know there's a
there's it's a tricky thing because as
soon as you put randomness in you have
to know you know what how much of what's
coming out is what you put in versus how
much is actually something that's being
generated and what's really nice about
these systems where you just have very
simple initial conditions and where you
get random stuff out or seemingly random
stuff out is you don't have that issue
you don't have to argue about was that
something complicated put in because
it's plainly obvious there wasn't now as
a practical matter in doing experiments
the big thing is if the thing you see
is complex and reproducible
then it didn't come from just filtering
some quotes randomness from the outside
world it has to be something that is
intrinsically made because it wouldn't
otherwise be i mean you know the the
it could be the case that you set things
up and it's always the same each time
and you say well it's kind of the same
but it's not then it's not random each
time because kind of the definition of
it being random is it was kind of picked
picked at random each time so to speak
so is it possible to for sure know that
our universe does not at the fundamental
level have randomness is it possible to
conclusively say
there's no randomness at the bottom
well it's an interesting question i mean
you know
science natural science is an inductive
business right you observe a bunch of
things and you say can we fit these
together what is our hypothesis for
what's going on the thing that i think i
can say fairly definitively is at this
point we understand enough about
fundamental physics
that there is if there was sort of an
extra dice being thrown
it's something that doesn't need to be
there we can get what we see without
that
now
you know could you add that in as an
extra little featuroid
um you know without breaking the
universe uh probably but in fact almost
certainly yes but is it necessary for
understanding the universe no and i
think actually from a a more fundamental
point of view
it's
it's
i think i might be able to argue so so
one of the things that i've been
interested in have been pretty surprised
that i've had anything sentient to say
about is the question of why does the
universe exist
i didn't think that was a question that
i would you know i thought that was a
far out there metaphysical kind of thing
uh even the philosophers have stayed
away from that question for the most
part it's so such a kind of
you know difficult to address question
but i actually think to my great
surprise that from our physics project
and so on that it is possible to
actually uh address that question and
explain why the universe exists and i
kind of have a suspicion i've not
thought it through i kind of have a
suspicion that that explanation will
eventually show you that
in no meaningful sense can there be
randomness underneath the universe that
is that if there is
it's something that is necessarily
irrelevant to our perception of the
universe that is that it could be there
but it doesn't matter because in a sense
we've already you know whatever it would
do whatever extra thing it would add is
not relevant to our perception of what's
going on so why
does the universe exist how does uh the
irrelevance of randomness connect to uh
the big why question of silver so okay
so i mean why does the universe exist
well let's see and uh is this the only
universe we got it's the only one
that about that i'm pretty sure so now
you may be which one
which of these topics is better to enter
first why does the universe exist and uh
why you think it's the only one that
exists well i think they're very closely
related okay okay
so i mean the first thing
let's see i mean this why does the
universe exist question
is built on top of all these things that
we've been figuring out about
fundamental physics
because if you want to know why the
universe exists you kind of have to know
what the universe is made of
and
i think the um well let me let me uh
describe a little bit about
the why does the universe exist question
so the main issue is let's say you have
a model for the universe
and you say i've got this this program
or something and you run it and you make
the universe
now you say well how do you actually why
is that program actually running and
people say you've got this program that
makes the universe what computer is it
running on
right what what does it mean what
actualizes something you know two plus
two equals four but that's different
from saying there's two a pile of two
rocks another pile of two rocks and so
many moves them together and makes four
so to speak and so what is it that kind
of turns it from being just this formal
thing to being something that is
actualized
okay so there we have to start thinking
about well well what do we actually know
about what's going on in the universe
well we are observers of this universe
but confusingly enough we're part of
this universe so in a sense we what what
what if we say what do we what do we
know about what's going on in the
universe well what we know is what sort
of our consciousness records about
what's going on in the universe
and so consciousness is part of the
fabric of the universe so we're in it
yes we're in it and and maybe i should
maybe i should start off by saying
something about the consciousness story
because that that's um yes
maybe we should begin
even before that at the very base layer
of the wolfram physics project
maybe you can give a broad overview once
again
really quick about this hypergraph model
yes and also what is it a year and a
half ago since you've brought this
project to the world what is the status
update
where what are all the beautiful ideas
you have come across
uh what are the interesting things you
can always mention it's i mean it's a
it's a freaking cambrian explosion i
mean it's it's crazy i mean there are
all these things which i've kind of
wondered about for years and suddenly
there's actually a way to think about
them and i really did not see
i mean the real strength of what's
happened i absolutely did not see coming
and the real strength of it is we've got
this model for physics but it turns out
it's a foundational kind of model that's
a different kind of computation-like
model that i'm kind of calling the sort
of multi-computational model
and that that kind of model is
applicable not only to physics but also
to lots of other kinds of things
and one reason that's extremely powerful
is because physics has been very
successful so we know a lot based on
what we figured out in physics and if we
know that the same model governs physics
and governs i don't know economics
linguistics immunology whatever
we know that the same kind of model
governs those things we can start using
things that we've successfully
discovered in physics and applying those
intuitions in all these other areas and
that's that's pretty exciting and and
very surprising to me um and in fact
it's kind of like in the original story
of sort of you go and you explain why is
there complexity in the natural world
then you realize well there's all this
complexity there's all this
computational irreducibility you know
there's a lot we can't know about what's
going to happen it's kind of it's kind
of very confusing thing for people who
say you know science has nailed
everything down we're going to you know
based on science we can know everything
well actually there's this computational
irreducibility thing right in the middle
of that
thrown up by science so to speak and
then the question is well given
computational irreducibility how can we
actually figure out anything about what
happens in the world why aren't we
why are we able to predict anything why
are we able to operate in the world and
the answer is that we sort of live in
these slices of computational
reusability that exists in this kind of
ocean of computational irreducibility
and it turns out that seems that it's a
very fundamental feature of the kind of
model that seems to operate in physics
and perhaps in a lot of these other
areas that there are these particular
slices of computational reducibility
that are relevant to us
and those are the things that both allow
us to operate in the world and not just
have everything be completely
unpredictable but there are also things
that potentially give us what amount to
sort of physics-like laws in all these
other areas so that's that's been sort
of an exciting thing but but i would say
that in general for our project it's
been going spectacularly well i mean i
you know i it's very honestly it wasn't
something i expected to happen in my
lifetime i mean it's you know it's
something where
where it's it's and in fact
one of the things about it some of the
things that we've discovered are things
where i was pretty sure that wasn't how
things worked
and turns out i'm wrong and you know
in a major area in metal mathematics i
i'd be realizing that i something i've
long believed we can talk about it
later that that that uh just just really
isn't right but but i think that um
the um the thing that uh so so what's
happened with the physics project i mean
you know it's a
it can explain a little bit about how
the how the model works but basically we
can maybe ask you uh the following
question so
it's easy through words describe how
cellular automotive works you've
explained this
and uh it's the fundamental mechanism by
which you in your book and your kind of
science explored the idea of complexity
and how to do science in this world of
isla reducible islands and irreducible
general irreducibility okay so how does
the model of hypergraphs differ from
cellular and how does the idea of
multi-computation
differ like maybe that's a way to
describe it right we're yeah right this
is a you know my life is like all of our
lives something of a story of
computational irreducibility yes and you
know it's been going for a few years now
so it's always a challenge to kind of
find these appropriate pockets of
reducibility but let me see what i can
do great so so i mean first of all let's
let's talk about physics first of all
and you know a key observation
that one of the starting point of our
physics project is
things about what is space what is the
universe made of
and you know ever since euclid people
just sort of say space is just this
thing where you can put things at any
position you want
and they're just points and they're just
geometrical things that you can just
arbitrarily put at different different
coordinate positions so the first thing
in our physics project is the idea that
space is made of something just like
water is made of molecules space is made
of kind of atoms of space
and the only thing we can say about
these atoms of space is they have some
identity there's a there's a there is
it's this atom as opposed to this atom
and you know you could give them if
you're a computer person you give them
uuids or something
yes and and um but that's all there is
to say about them so to speak um and
then
all we know about these atoms of space
is how they relate to each other so we
say these three atoms of space
are associated with each other in some
relation so you can think about that as
you know what atom of space is friends
with what other atom of space you can
build this essentially friend network of
the atoms of space
and the sort of starting point of our
physics project is that's what our
universe is it's a giant friend network
of the atoms of space
and so how can that possibly represent
our universe well it's like in
something like water you know they're
molecules bouncing around but on a large
scale that
you know that produces fluid flow and we
have fluid vortices and we have all of
these phenomena that are sort of the
emergent phenomena from that underlying
uh kind of collection of molecules
bouncing around and by the way it's
important that that collection of
molecules bouncing around
have this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that's actually what
leads to the second law of
thermodynamics among other things
and that leads to the sort of randomness
of the underlying behavior which is what
gives you something which on a large
scale seems like it's a smooth
continuous
type of thing and so so okay so first
thing is space is made of something it's
made of all these atoms of space
connected together in this network and
then everything that we experience
is sort of features of the of that
structure of space so you know when we
have an electron or something or a
photon it's some kind of tangle in the
structure of space much like kind of a
vortex and a fluid would be just this
thing that is you know it it can
actually the vortex can move around it
can involve different molecules in the
fluid but the vortex still stays there
and if you zoom out enough the vortex
looks like an atom itself like a basic
element yes so there's the levels of
abstraction
if you squint and kind of blur things
out it looks like at every level of
abstraction you can define what is a
basic
individual entities yes but but you know
in in this model
there's a bottom level yeah you know
there's an elementary length maybe
that's
100 10 to the minus 100 meters let's say
which is really small you know proton is
10 to the minus 15 meters the smallest
we've ever been able to sort of see
where the particle accelerator is around
10 to the minus 21 meters so you know if
we don't know precisely what the correct
scale is but it's perhaps over the order
of 10 to the minus 100 meters so it's
pretty small um and but but that's
that's the end that's that's what things
are made of what's your intuition where
the 10 to the minus 100 comes from
what's your intuition about this scale
well okay so there's a calculation which
i consider to be somewhat rickety okay
which has to do with comparing so so
there are various fundamental constants
there's the speed of light the speed of
light once you know the elementary time
the speed of light is tells you the
conversion from the elementary time to
the elementary length then there's the
question of how do you convert to the
elementary energy and how do you convert
to between other things and the various
constants we know we know the speed of
light we know the gravitational constant
we know planck's constant and quantum
mechanics those are the three important
ones and we actually know some other
things we know things like the size of
the universe the hubble constant things
like that
and essentially this calculation of the
elementary length comes from looking at
these sort of combination of those okay
so the most obvious thing people have
sort of assumed that quantum gravity
happens at this thing the planck scale
10 minus 34 meters which is the sort of
the the combination of planck's constant
and the gravitational constant the speed
of light that gives you that kind of
length
turns out in our model there is an
additional parameter which is
essentially the number of simultaneous
threads of execution of the universe
which is essentially the number of sort
of independent quantum uh processes that
are going on and that number let's see
if i remember that number that number is
10 to 170 i think and and so it's a big
number but um that number
then connects you know sort of modifies
what you might think from all these
planck
uh
units to give you the things we're
giving and there's been sort of a
mystery actually in the in the more
technical physics thing that the planck
mass
the plank energy
plank energy is actually surprisingly
big the planck length is tiny 10 minus
34 meters that you know planck time 10
minus 43 meters i think seconds i think
um but the planck energy is like uh is
like the the energy of a of a lightning
strike okay which is pretty weird in our
models the actual elementary energy is
that divided by the number of sort of
simultaneous quantum threads and it ends
up being really small too and that's
sort of explains that mystery that's
been around for a while about about how
plank units work
but but that you know whether that
precise estimate is right we don't know
yet i mean that that that's one of the
things that's sort of been a thing we've
been pretty interested in is how do you
see through you know how does you how do
you make a gravitational microscope that
can kind of see through to the atoms of
space you know how do you get in in
fluid flow for example if you go to
hypersonic flow or something you know
you've got a mark 20 you know space
plane or something it really matters
that there are individual molecules
hitting the space plane not a continuous
fluid the question is what is the
analogous kind of
what is the analog of hypersonic flow
for
for our for things about the structure
of space time and it looks like uh a a
rapidly rotating black hole right at the
sort of critical rotation rate um is
it looks as if that's a case where
essentially the the structure of space
time is just about to fall apart
and you may be able to kind of see
the evidence of sort of discrete
uh elements you know you may be able to
kind of see there the sort of
gravitational microscope of actually
seeing these discrete elements of space
and there may be some effect in for
example gravitational waves produced by
rapidly rotating black hole that in
which one could actually see some
phenomenon where one can say yes they
don't come out the way one would expect
based on having a continuous structure
of space time that it is something where
you can kind of see through to the
discrete structure um we don't know that
yet so you can maybe elaborate a little
bit deeper hollow microscope that
concedes a 10 to the minus
100
how rotating black holes
and uh presumably the
the the detailed accurate detection of
gravitational waves from since black
holes can reveal the discreteness of
space
okay first thing is what is a black hole
uh actually we we need to go a little
bit further in the story of what space
time is because i explained a little bit
about what space is but it didn't talk
about what time is and that's sort of
important in in understanding space time
so to speak and your sense is both space
and time in the story are discreet
absolutely
absolutely but it's a complicated story
yes and um needless to say well it's
simple at the bottom
it's it's very simple at the bottom it's
it's very in the end
it's simple but deeply abstract and um
and something that is
simple in conception but kind of
wrapping one's head around what's going
on is pretty hard
um but so so first of all we have this
so you know i've described these kind of
atoms of space and their connections you
can think about these things as a
hypergraph you know a graph is just you
connect nodes to nodes but a hypergraph
you can have you know uh you can have
sort of not just friends
individual friends to friends but you
can have these triplets of of friends or
whatever else it's it's um and so we're
just saying and that's just the
relations between atoms of space are the
hyper edges of the hypograph and so
we've got some big collection of of
these atoms of space maybe 10 to the 400
or something in our in our universe um
and that's the structure of space that's
and every feature of what we experience
in the world is a feature of that that
hypergraph that spatial hypograph
so then the question is well how does
what does that spatial hypergraph do
well the idea is that there are rules
that that update that spatial hypograph
and you know in a cellular automaton
you've just got this line of cells and
you just say it every step at every time
step you've got fixed time steps fixed
array of cells at every step uh every
cell gets updated according to a certain
rule
and that's um that's kind of the that's
the way it works now in this hypograph
it's sort of vaguely the same kind of
thing we say every time you see a little
piece of hypergraph that looks like this
update it to one that looks like this so
it's just keep rewriting this hypergraph
every time you see something looks like
that anywhere in the universe it gets
rewritten now one thing that's tricky
about that which we'll come to is this
multi-computational idea which has to do
with you're not saying in in some kind
of lock-step way do this one then this
one then this one it's just whenever you
see one you can do you can go ahead and
do it and that leads one not to have a
single thread of time in the universe
because if you knew which one to do you
just say okay we do this one then we do
this one then we do this one but if you
say just do whichever one you feel like
you end up with these multiple threads
of time these kind of multiple histories
of the universe depending on which order
you happen to do the things you could do
in
so it's fundamentally asynchronous and
parallel yes
yes which is very uncomfortable for the
human brain that seeks for things to be
sequential
and synchronous right well i think that
this is this is part of the story of
consciousness
is i think the key aspect of
consciousness that is important for sort
of parsing the universe is this point
that we have a single thread of
experience right we have a memory of
what happened in the past we can say
something predict something about the
future but there's a single thread of
experience and it's not obvious it
should work that way i mean we've got
100 billion neurons in our brains and
they're all firing in all kinds of
different ways but yet our experiences
that there is the single thread of of of
time that that goes that that goes along
and i think that you know one of the
things i've kind of realized with a lot
more clarity in the last year
is the fact that our the fact that we
conclude that the universe has the laws
it has is a consequence of the fact that
we have consciousness the way we have
consciousness
and so the fact so i mean just to go on
with kind of the the basic setup it's uh
so we've got this spatial hypograph it's
got all these atoms of space they're
getting they're getting these little
clumps of atoms of space they're getting
turned into other clumps of atoms of
space and that's happening everywhere in
the universe all the time and so one
thing it's a little bit weird is there's
nothing permanent in the universe
the universe is getting rewritten
everywhere all the time and if it wasn't
getting rewritten it would space
wouldn't be knitted together that is
space would just fall apart there
wouldn't be any way in which we could
say this part of space is next to this
part of space you know one of the things
that i was
people were confused about back in
antiquity you know the ancient greek
philosophers and so on is how does
motion work
you know how can it be the case that you
can take a thing that we can walk around
and it's still us when we walked you
know a foot forward so to speak and in a
sense with our models that's again a
question because it's a different set of
atoms of space when we you know when i
move my hand it's it's moving into a
different set of atoms of space it's
having to be recreated it's not the
thing itself is not there it's it's
being continuously recreated all the
time now it's a little bit like waves in
an ocean you know vortices in a fluid
which again the actual molecules that
exist in those are not what define the
identity of the thing
and but it's a little bit uh you know
this idea that there can be pure motion
that it can that it is even possible for
an object to just move around in the
universe and not change
is it's not self-evident that such a
thing should be possible and that is
part of our perception of the universe
is that we
we parse those aspects of the universe
where things like pure motion are
possible now pure motion even in general
relativity the theory of gravity um pure
motion is a little bit of a complicated
thing i mean if you imagine your average
you know teacup or something approaching
a black hole it is deformed and
distorted by the structure of space time
and to say you know is it really pure
motion is it that same teacup that's the
same shape well it's a bit of a
complicated story
and this is a more extreme version of
that so so anyway the the thing that
that's happening is we've got space
we've got this notion of time so time is
this kind of this rewriting of the
hypograph and one of the things that's
important about that time is this sort
of computationally irreducible process
there's something you know time is not
something where
in kind of the mathematical view of of
time tends to be time is just to
coordinate we can you know slide a
slider turn a knob and we'll change the
the time that we've got in this equation
but in this picture of time that's not
how it works at all time is this
inexorable irreducible kind of set of
computations that go on that go from
where we are now to the future but so so
the thing and one of the things that is
again something one sort of has to break
out of is your average trained physicist
like me says you know space and time are
the same kind of thing they're related
by you know the prank array group and
and lawrence transformations and
relativity and all these kinds of things
and you know space and time uh you know
there are all these kind of sort of folk
stories you can tell about why space and
time is the same kind of thing
in this model they're fundamentally not
the same kind of thing space is this
kind of sort of connections between
these atoms of space time is this
computational process so the thing that
the first sort of surprising thing is
well it turns out you get relativity
anyway and the reason that happens the
few bits and pieces here which one has
to understand but but the the
fundamental point is if you are an
observer embedded in the system
that are part of this whole story of
things getting updated in this way and
that
there are there's sort of a limit to
what you can tell about what's going on
and really in the end the only thing you
can tell is what are the causal
relationships between events
so an event
in this sort of
an elementary event is a little piece of
hypograph got rewritten and that means a
few hyper edges of the hyper graph were
consumed by the event
and you produce some other hyperedges
and that's an elementary event
and so then the question is uh what we
can tell is kind of what the network of
causal relationships between elementary
events is that's the ultimate thing the
causal graph of the universe
and it it turns out that well there's
this property of causal invariance that
is true of a bunch of these models and i
think is inevitably true for a variety
of reasons um that
makes it be the case that it doesn't
matter kind of if if you are
sort of saying well i've got this
hypograph and i can rewrite this piece
here and this piece here and i do them
all in different orders when you
construct the causal graph for each of
those orders that you choose to do
things in you'll end up with the same
causal graph
and so that's essentially why
uh well that's in the end why relativity
works
it's why our perception of space and
time is is as as having this kind of
connection that relativity says they
should have
and that's that's kind of that's kind of
how that works
i think i'm missing a little piece uh if
you can go there again you said
the fact that the observer is embedded
in this hypergraph
what's missing uh what is the observer
not able
to state about this universe so
basically if you look from the outside
you can say oh i see
this
uh
i see this particular place was updated
and then this one was updated and and
i'm seeing which order things were
updated in but the observer embedded in
the universe doesn't know which order
things were updated in because until
they've been updated they have no idea
what else happened so the only thing
they know is the set of causal
relationships let me give an extreme
example let's imagine that the universe
is a turing machine turing machines have
just this one update head which does
something and otherwise the turing
machine just does nothing right and and
the turing machine works by having this
head move around and do its updating uh
you know just where the head happens to
be the question is could the universe be
a turing machine could the universe just
have a single updating head that's just
zipping around all over the place you
say that's crazy because you know i'm
i'm talking to you you seem to be
updating i'm updating etc but the thing
is there's no way to know that because
if there was just this head moving
around it's like okay it updates me
but you're completely frozen at that
point until the head has come over and
updated you you have no idea what
happened to me
and so if you sort of unravel that
argument you realize the only thing we
actually can tell
is what the network of causal
relationships between the things that
happened were we don't get to know from
some sort of outside sort of god's eye
view of the thing we don't get to know
what sort of from the outside what
happened we only get to know sort of
what the set of relationships between
the things that happened actually were
yeah but if i somehow record like a
trace of this
i guess would be called
multi-computation
can't i uh then look back
in the way where do you look for the
trace
some you place throughout the universe
like throughout
like a log that records
in my own pocket of in this hyper graph
can i
like
realizing that i'm getting an outdated
picture
can't i record
see the problem is and this is where
things start getting
very entangled in terms of what one
understands the problem is that any such
recording device is itself part of the
universe yeah
so you don't get to say you never get to
say let's go outside the universe and go
do this
and and that's why i mean lots of the
features of this of this model and the
way things work end up being a result of
that so but what
i guess from on a human level what is
the cost you're paying what are you
missing from not getting an updated
picture all the time okay i got i i
understand what you should say yeah yeah
right but like what like how does
consciousness emerge from that
like how
like what are the limitations of that
observer i understand you're getting a
delay well that's true there's a okay
there's there's
a bunch of limitations of the observer i
think
maybe just explain something about
quantum mechanics because that maybe is
a is an extreme version of some of these
issues which helps to kind of motivate
why one should sort of think things
through a little bit more carefully
so one feature of the of this
okay so
in standard physics like high school
physics you learn you know the equations
of motion for a ball and the the you
know it says you throw the ball this
angle this velocity things will move in
this way and there's a definite answer
right the story the the key story of
quantum mechanics is there aren't
definite answers to where does the ball
go there's kind of this whole sort of
bundle of possible paths and all we say
we know from quantum mechanics is
certain probabilities for where the ball
will end up okay so that's kind of the
the core idea of quantum mechanics so in
our models you quantum mechanics is not
some kind of plug-in add-on type thing
you absolutely cannot get away from
quantum mechanics because as you think
about updating this hyper graph there
isn't just one sequence of things one
definite sequence of things that can
happen there are all these different
possible update sequences that can occur
you could do this you know piece of the
hypograph now and then this one later
and etc etc etc all those different
paths of history correspond to these
quantum quantum
paths and quantum mechanics these
different possible quantum histories and
one of the things that's kind of
surprising about it is they they branch
you know there can be a certain state of
the universe and it could do this or it
could do that but they can also merge
there can be two states of the universe
which their next state the next state
they produce is the same for both of
them and that process of branching and
merging is kind of critical and the idea
that they can be merging is critical and
somewhat non-trivial for these
hypographs because there's a whole graph
isomorphism story and there's a whole
very elaborate settlement that's where
the causal invariance comes in yes
among other things right okay yes that's
but but so so then what happens is that
what what one's seeing okay so we've got
this thing it's branching it's merging
et cetera et cetera et cetera okay so
now the question is how do we perceive
that
what do you know how do we do we why
don't we notice that the universe is
branching and merging
why you know why is it the case that we
just think a definite set of things
happen
well the answer is we are embedded in
that universe and our brains are
branching and merging too
and so what quantum mechanics becomes a
story of is how does a branching brain
perceive a branching universe
and the key thing is as soon as you say
i think definite things happen in the
universe that means you are essentially
conflating lots of different parts of
history you're saying
actually as far as i'm concerned because
i'm convinced that definite things
happen in the universe all these parts
of history must be equivalent now it's
not obvious that that would be a
consistent thing to do it might be you
say all these paths of history are
equivalent but by golly moments later
that would be a completely inconsistent
point of view everything would have you
know gone to hell in different ways the
fact that that doesn't happen
is well that's a consequence of this
causal and variance thing but that's and
the fact that that does happen a little
bit is what causes little quantum
effects
and that term if that didn't happen at
all there wouldn't be anything that sort
of is like quantum mechanics it would be
quantum mechanics is kind of like in
this uh in this kind of this bundle of
paths it's a little bit like what
happens in statistical mechanics and
fluid mechanics whatever that most of
the time you just see this continuous
fluid you just see the world just
progressing in this kind of way that's
like this continuous fluid but every so
often if you look at the exact right
experiment you can start seeing well
actually it's made of these molecules
where they might go that way or they
might go this way and that's kind of
quantum effects and and so that's so the
this kind of idea of
where we're sort of embedded in the
universe this branching brain is
perceiving this branching universe and
that ends up being sort of a story of
quantum mechanics that's that's part of
the the whole picture of what's going on
but i think i mean to come back to sort
of where does conscious what is what is
the story of consciousness so in the
universe
we've got you know whatever it is 10 to
the 400 atoms of space they're all doing
these complicated things
it's all a big complicated irreducible
computation the question is what do we
perceive from all of that
and the answer is that we are we are
parsing the universe
in a particular way
let me again go back to the the gas
molecules analogy you know in the gas in
this room there are molecules bouncing
around all kinds of complicated patterns
but we don't care all we notice is
there's you know the gas laws are
satisfied maybe there's some fluid
dynamics these are kind of features of
that assembly molecules that we notice
and then lots of details we don't notice
when you say we do you mean the tools of
physics or do you mean literally are the
human brain in its perception system
well okay so the human brain is where it
starts but we've built a bunch of
instruments to do a bit better than the
human brain but they still have many of
the same kinds of ideas you know their
cameras and their pressure sensors and
their these kinds of things they're not
uh you know at this point we don't know
how to make fundamentally qualitatively
different sensory devices right and so
it's always just an extension of the
conscious
experience or a sensory experience
sensory experience but
sensory experience that's somehow
intricately tied to
consciousness
right well so so one question is when we
are looking at all these molecules of
the in the gas and there might be 10 to
20 molecules in some little little box
or something it's like
what what do we notice about those
molecules so one thing that we can say
is we don't notice that much
we are you know we are computationally
bounded observers we can't go in and say
okay i'm they're 10 to the 20th
molecules and i know that i can sort of
decrypt their motions and i can figure
out this and that it's like i'm just
going to say what's the average density
of molecules and so one key feature of
us is that we are computationally
bounded and that when you are looking at
a universe which is full of computation
and doing huge amounts of computation
but we are computationally bounded
there's only certain things about that
universe that we're going to be
sensitive to we're not going to be you
know figuring out what all the atoms of
space are doing because we're just
computationally bounded observers and we
are only sampling these these small set
of features so i i think the two
defining features of consciousness that
and i
you know i would say that the the sort
of the the preamble to this is
for years you know because i've talked
about sort of computation and
fundamental features of physics and
science
people ask me so what about
consciousness
and i for years i've said i have nothing
to say about consciousness
and you know i've kind of told this
story you know you talk about
intelligence you talk about life
these are both features where you say
what's the abstract definition of life
we don't really know the abstract
definition we know the one for life on
earth it's got rna it's got cell
membranes it's got all this kind of
stuff
similarly for intelligence we know the
human definition of intelligence but
what is intelligence abstractly we don't
really know and so what i've long
believed is that sort of the abstract
definition of intelligence is just
computational sophistication that is
that as soon as you can be
computationally sophisticated that's
kind of the abstract version the
generalized version of intelligence so
then the question is what about
consciousness and what i sort of
realized is that consciousness is
actually a step down from intelligence
that is that you might think oh you know
consciousness is the is the is the top
of the pile but actually i don't think
it is i think that there's this notion
of kind of computational sophistication
which is the generalized intelligence
but consciousness has two limitations i
think one of them is computational
boundedness that is that we're only
perceiving a sort of computationally
bounded view of the universe and the
other is this idea of a single thread of
time
that is that we and in fact we know
neurophysiologically our brains go to
some trouble to give us this one thread
of attention so to speak and it isn't
the case that you know in all the
neurons in our brains that that uh in at
least in our conscious
know the the you know the correspondence
of language in our conscious experience
we just have the single thread of
attention single thread of of perception
um and you know maybe there's something
unconscious that's bubbling around
that's the kind of almost the quantum
version of what's happening in our brain
so to speak we've got the the classical
flow of what we are mostly thinking
about so to speak but there's this kind
of bubbling around of other paths that
is all those other neurons that didn't
make it to be part of our sort of
conscious stream of experience so in
that sense intelligence as computational
sophistication is much broader
than uh yes then the the computational
constraints
which
consciousness operates under and also
the sequential like the sequential thing
yes like the notion of time
that's that's kind of interesting but
then the the follow-up question is like
okay starting to get a sense of what is
intelligence and how does that connect
to a human brain because you're saying
um
intelligence is almost like a fabric
like what we like plug into it or
something like yeah i think you know our
consciousness plugs into it yeah i mean
the intelligence i think the core
i mean you know intelligence at some
level is just a word but we're asking
you know what is the the notion of
intelligence as we generalize it beyond
the bounds of humans beyond the bounds
of even the ais that we humans have
built and so on you know what what is
intelligence you know is the weather you
know people say the weather has a mind
of its own what does that mean you know
can the weather be intelligent
yeah what does agency have to do with
intelligence here so is intelligence
just like your conception of computation
just intelligence
is a
is the capacity to perform computation
and the sea of yeah i think so i mean i
think that's right and i i think that
you know this question of of is it for a
purpose okay
that quickly degenerates into a horrible
philosophical mess because you know
whenever you say
did the weather do that for a purpose
yeah right well yes it did it was trying
to move a bunch of hot air from the
equator to the poles or something that's
its purpose but why because i seem to be
equally as dumb today as i was yesterday
so there's some persistence like uh
consistency over time that the
intelligence i plugged into
so like what's it seems like there's a
hard constraint
well between the amount of computation i
can perform in my consciousness
like they seem to be really closely
connected somehow well i think the point
is that the thing that gives you kind of
the ability to have
kind of conscious
intel intelligence
you you can have kind of this okay so so
one thing is we don't know
intelligences other than the ones that
are very much like us yes right and the
ones that are very much like us i think
have this feature of single thread of
time
bounded you know computationally bounded
now that but you also need computational
sophistication having a single thread of
time and being computationally bounded
you could just be a clock going
tick-tock you know that would satisfy
those conditions but the fact that we
have this uh sort of uh irreducible
you know computational ability that's
that's an important feature that's
that's the sort of the the bedrock on
which we can construct the things we
construct now the fact that we have this
experience of the world that has the
single thread of time and computational
boundedness the thing that i sort of
realized is
it's that that causes us
to deduce from this irreducible mess of
what's going on in the physical world
the laws of physics that we think exist
so in other words if we say why do we
believe that there is you know
continuous space let's say why do we
believe that gravity works the way it
does
well in principle we could be kind of
parsing details of the universe
that were uh you know that
okay the analogy is uh again with
the you know statistical mechanics and
molecules in a box we could be sensitive
to every little detail of the swirling
around those molecules and we could say
what really matters
is the you know the wiggle effect yes
that is um you know that is something
that we humans just never notice because
it's some weird thing that happens when
there are 15 collisions of air molecules
and this happens and that happens we
just see the pure motion of a ball yeah
moving about right why do we see that
right and the point is that that what
seems to be the case is that the things
that if if we say given this sort of
hypergraph that's updating and all the
details about all the sort of uh sort of
atoms of space and what they do and we
say how do we slice that to what we can
be sensitive to what seems to be the
case is that as soon as we assume
you know computational boundedness
single thread of time that leads us to
general relativity in other words we
can't avoid that that that's the way
that we we will parse the universe given
those constraints we parse the universe
according to
those particular uh
in such a way that we say the aggregate
reducible copy
sort of computate pocket of
computational reducibility that we slice
out of this kind of whole computational
irreducible ocean of behavior is just
this one that corresponds to general
relativity yeah but we don't perceive
general relativity
well we do if we do fancy experiments so
you're saying so perceive really does
mean the force we drop something that's
a that's a great example of general
relativity in action the graph no but
like what's the difference between that
and newtonian mechanics i mean oh it
doesn't i this is i when i say general
relativity that's gravity uber the uber
theory so to speak i mean newtonian
gravity is just the approximation that
we can make you know
on the earth and things like that so so
this is you know the phenomenon of
gravity is one that is a consequence of
you know we would perceive something
very different from gravity so so the
way to understand that is when we think
about okay so
we make up reference frames with which
we parse what's happening in space and
time
so in other words one of the one of the
things that we do
is we say
as time progresses
uh everywhere in space
is something happens at a particular
time and then we go to the next time and
we say this is what space is like at the
next time there's what space is like at
the next time
that's it's the reason we are used to
doing that
is because you know when we look around
we might see you know 10 100 meters away
um the time it takes light to travel
that distance is really short compared
to the time it takes our brains to know
what happened so as far as our brains
are concerned we are parsing the
universe in this there is a moment in
time it's all of space there's a moment
in time it's all of space you know if we
were the size of planets or something we
would have a different perception
because the speed of light would be much
more important to us we wouldn't have
this perception that
things happen progressively in time
everywhere in space
and so that's an important kind of
constraint and the reason that we kind
of parse the universe in the way that
causes us to say gravity works the way
it does is because we're doing things
like deciding that we can say the
universe exists space has a definite
structure
there is a moment in time space has this
definite structure we move to the next
moment in time space as another
structure that kind of set up is what
lets us kind of deduce
kind of what to parse the universe in
such a way that we say gravity works the
way it does so uh that kind of reference
frame is that the illusion of that is
that
you're saying that somehow useful for
consciousness
that's what consciousness does because
in a sense what consciousness is doing
is there are uh
it's it's insisting that the universe is
kind of sequentialized right that is um
and it is not allowing the possibility
that oh there are these multiple threads
of time and they're all flowing
differently it's like saying no you know
everything is happening in this one
thread of experience that we have and
that illusion of that one thread of
experience cannot happen at the
planetary scale so are you saying
typical human are you saying we are at a
human level especially
here for consciousness like well for our
kind of consciousness it's it's uh you
know if we existed at a scale close to
the elementary length for example then
our perception of the universe will be
absurdly different okay so but this
makes this consciousness seem like a
weird side effect to this particular
scale
and so who cares i mean
consciousness is not that special i i
think look i think that a very
interesting question is which i've
certainly thought a little bit about
is what can you imagine what is a sort
of factoring of something you know what
are some other possible ways you could
exist so to speak right and you know if
you were a photon if you were sort of
you know some kind of thing that was
some uh kind of you know
intelligence represented in terms of
photons you know for example the photons
we receive in the cosmic microwave
background those photons as far as
they're concerned the universe just
started they they they were emitted you
know 100 000 years after the beginning
of the universe they've been traveling
at the speed of light time stayed still
for them and then they just arrived and
we just detected them so for them the
universe just started and that's a
different perception of you know that
has implications for a very different
perception of time they don't have that
single thread that seems to be
really important for being able to tell
a heck of a good story so we humans
we can tell a story
right we can tell a story what other
kind of stories can you tell so photon
is a really boring story
yeah i mean so that's a i don't know if
they're a boring story but i i think
it's you know i've been wondering about
this and i've been asking you know
friends of mine who are science fiction
writers and things have you written
stuff about this and i've got one
example good great great
collection of books from my friend rudy
rooker which were um uh which i have to
say the um they're books about uh that
are very informed by a bunch of science
that i've done and the thing that i
really loved about them is you know you
know in the in the first chapter of the
of the book the the earth is consumed by
these things he called nance which are
nano nanobot type things and
but so you know so the earth is gone in
the first but then it comes back but but
um but then spoiler alert yeah right
that was uh that was only a microspot
it's only chapter one okay it's it's um
the but but uh the thing that um is is
not a real spoiler alert because it's
such a complicated concept but but in
the end in the end the the earth is
saved by this thing called the principle
of computational equivalence which is a
kind of a core scientific idea of mine
and i was just like like thrilled i i
don't read fiction books very often um
and i was just thrilled i get to the end
of this and it's like oh my gosh you
know everything is saved by this sort of
deep scientific principle can you can
you maybe elaborate how the principle of
computational equivalence
can save
a planet
that would that would be a have a
terrible spoiler for me that would be a
spoiler okay yeah but but no but let me
say what the principle of computational
equivalence is
um
so the question is
you are
you have a system you have some rule
you can think of its behavior as
corresponding to a computation
the question is how sophisticated is
that computation
the statement of the principle of
computational equivalence is as soon as
it's it's not obviously simple it will
be as sophisticated as anything and so
that has the implication that you know
rule 30
you know our brains
other things in physics they're all
ultimately equivalent in the
computations they can do and that's what
leads to this computational
irreducibility idea because the reason
we don't get to jump ahead you know and
out think rule 30 is because we're just
computationally equivalent to rule 30 so
we're kind of just both just running
computations
that are the same sort of raw the same
level of computation so to speak so
that's kind of the the idea there and
the question i mean it's it's like uh
the you know in in the science fiction
version would be okay somebody says we
just need more servers get us more
servers the way to get even more servers
is turn the whole planet into a bunch of
micro servers
and that that's uh that's where it
starts and so the question of you know
computational equivalence principle of
computational equivalence is well
actually you don't need to build those
custom servers actually you can uh you
can just
use natural computation to compute
things so to speak you can use nature to
compute you don't need to have done all
that engineering i mean it's kind of the
it's it's kind of feels a little
disappointing that you say we're going
to build all these servers we're going
to do all these things we're going to
make you know maybe we're going to have
human consciousness uploaded into you
know some elaborate digital environment
and then you look at that thing and you
say it's got electrons moving around
just like in a rock
and then you say well what's the
difference and the principle of
computational equivalence says there
isn't at some level a fundamental you
know you can't say mathematically
there's a fundamental difference between
the rock that is the future of human
consciousness and the rock that's just a
rock
now what i've sort of realized with this
kind of consciousness thing is there is
a there is an aspect of this that seems
to be more special that isn't and and
for example something i i haven't really
teased apart properly is when it comes
to something like the weather and the
weather having a mind of its own or
whatever or your average you know pulsar
magnetosphere acting like a sort of
intelligent thing how does that relate
to you know how how do how is that
that entity related to the kind of
consciousness that we have and sort of
what would the world look like you know
to the weather if we think about the
weather as a mind
what will it perceive what will it laws
its laws of physics be i don't really
know
because it's very parallel it's very
parallel among other things and it it
it's not obvious i mean this is a a
really kind of mind-bending thing
because we've got to try and imagine
where
uh you know we've got to try and imagine
a parsing of the universe different from
the one we have and by the way when we
think about extraterrestrial
intelligence and so on i think that's
kind of the key thing is you know we've
always assumed i've always assumed okay
the extraterrestrials at least they have
the same physics we all live in the same
universe they've got the same physics
but actually that's not really right
because the extraterrestrials could have
a completely different way of parsing
that the universe so it's as if you know
there could be for all we know right
here in this room you know in the in the
details of the motion of these gas
molecules there could be an amazing
intelligence that we were like but we
have no way of we're not parsing the
universe in the same way if only we
could parse the universe in the right
way you know immediately this amazing
thing that's going on and this you know
huge culture that's developed and all
that kind of thing would be obvious to
us but it's not because we have a
particular way of passing the universe
would that thing also have us
agency i don't know the right word to
use but something like consciousness but
a different kind of consciousness
i think it's a question of just what you
mean by the word because i think that
the you know this notion of
consciousness and the
okay so some people think of
consciousness as sort of a key aspect of
it is that we feel that
the the sort of a feeling of that we
exist in some way that we have this
intrinsic feeling about ourselves
you know i i suspect that any of these
things would also have an intrinsic
feeling about themselves i've been sort
of trying to think recently about
constructing an experiment about what if
you were just a piece of a cellular
automaton let's say you know what would
your feeling about yourself actually be
and you know can we put ourselves in the
in the shoes and the cells of the
cellular automaton so to speak can we
can we get ourselves close enough to
that that we could have a sense of what
the world would be like if you were
operating in that way and it's a little
difficult because you know you have to
not only think about what are you
perceiving but also what's actually
going on in your brain and our brains do
what they actually do and they don't
it's you know i think there might be
some experiments that are possible with
with uh you know neural nets and so on
where you can have something where you
can at least see in detail what's
happening inside the system and i i've
been sort of one of the one of my
projects to think about is is there a
way of kind of uh
kind of getting a sense kind of from
inside the system about what its view of
the world is and and how it how it you
know uh can can we make a bridge see the
main issue is this
where you know it's a it's a sort of
philosophically difficult thing because
it's like we do what we do we understand
ourselves um at least to some extent we
humans understand ourselves that's
correct and but yet okay so what are we
trying to do for example when we are
trying to make a model of physics what
are we actually trying to do because you
know you say well can we work out what
the universe does well of course we can
we just watch the universe the universe
does what it does but what we're trying
to do when we make a model of physics is
we're trying to get to the point where
we can tell a story to ourselves that we
understand
that is also a representation of what
the universe does so it's this kind of
you know can we make a bridge between
what we humans can understand in our
minds and what the universe does
and in a sense you know a large part of
my kind of life uh efforts have been
devoted to making computational language
which kind of is a bridge between what
is possible in the computational
universe and what we humans can
conceptualize and think about in a sense
what you know when i built wolfram
language and our whole sort of
computational language story it's all
about how do you take sort of raw
computation and this ocean of
computational possibility and how do we
sort of represent pieces of it in a way
that we humans can understand and that
map on to things that we care about
doing and in a sense when you add
physics you're adding this other piece
where we can you know mediate it by
computer can we get physics to the point
where we humans can understand something
about what's happening in it
and when we talk about an alien
intelligence it's kind of the same story
it's like is there a way of mapping
what's happening there onto something
that we humans can understand
and you know physics in some sense is
like
our exhibit one of the story of alien
intelligence it's it's a it's a you know
it's an alien intelligence in some sense
and what we're doing in making a model
of physics
is mapping that onto something that we
understand and i think you know a lot of
these other things that have i've
recently been kind of studying uh
whether it's molecular biology other
kinds of things um which we can talk
about a bit um the um
uh those are other cases where we're in
a sense trying to again make that bridge
between what we humans understand and
sort of the the natural language of that
sort of alien intelligence in some sense
when you're talking about just uh to
backtrack a little bit about cellular
automata
being able to uh what's it like to be a
cellular automata
in a way that's equivalent to what is it
like to be a conscious human being
how do you approach that so
is it looking at some subset of the
cellular autonomy asking questions of
that subset
like how the world is perceived
how yeah something like as that subset
like for that local pocket of
computation what are you able to say
about the broader something like that
and that somehow then
can give you a sense of how to step
outside of that cell right but but the
tricky part is
that that little subset
it's what it's doing is it has a view of
itself and the question is how do you
get inside it it's like you know when we
with humans right it's like we can't get
inside each other's consciousness
that doesn't really um you know that
doesn't really even make sense it's like
there is an experience that somebody is
having but you can perceive things from
the outside but sort of getting inside
it it doesn't it doesn't quite make
sense and i you know for me these sort
of philosophical issues and this one i
have not untangled so let's let's be um
sure um the you know for me the thing
that has been really interesting and
thinking through some of these things is
you know when it comes to questions
about consciousness or whatever else
it's like when i can run a program and
actually see pictures and you know make
things concrete i have a much better
chance to understand what's going on
than when i'm just trying to reason
about things in a very abstract way yeah
but there may be a way to uh
map
the program to your conscious experience
so for example when you play a video
game you do a first person shooter you
walk around inside
this entity yep it's a very different
thing than watching this entity so if
you can somehow
connect more and more connect
this full conscious experience
to the subset of the cellular automata
yeah it's something like that but the
difference in the first person shooter
thing is they're still
your brain and your memory is still
remembering you know you you still have
it's it's hard to i mean again what
one's going to get
one is not going to actually be able to
be the cellular automaton one's going to
be able to watch what the cellular
automaton does but this is the
frustrating thing that i'm trying to
understand you know you know how to how
to think about being it so to speak okay
so like in virtual reality there's a
concept of immersion like with anything
with video game with books there's a
concept of immersion it feels like over
time if the virtual reality experience
is is well done and maybe in the future
would be extremely well done
the immersion leads you to
feel like you mentioned memories you
forget
that you even ever existed outside that
experience
yeah so immersive
i mean you could argue sort of
mathematically that you can never truly
become immersed but maybe you can i mean
well yeah i mean why can't you merge
with the cellular automata yeah right i
mean you're
just part of the same fabric why can't
you just like well that's a good
question i mean so so let's imagine the
following scenario let's imagine you
return
what's that well but then can you return
back well yeah right i mean it's it's
like let's imagine you've uploaded you
know your brain is scanned you've got
every synapse you know mapped out
you upload everything about you the
brain simulator you upload the brain
simulator and the brain simulator is
basically you know some glorified
cellular automaton and then you say well
now we've got an answer to what does it
feel like to be a cellular automaton it
feels just like it felt to be ordinary
you because they're both computational
systems and they're both you know
operating in the same way so in a sense
but i think there's there's somehow more
to it because in that sense when you're
just making a brain simulator it's just
you know we're just saying there's
another version of our consciousness the
question that we're asking is if we
tease away from our consciousness and
get to something that is different how
do we make a bridge to understanding
what's going on there and you know
there's a way of thinking about this
okay so this is coming on to sort of
questions about the existence of the
universe and so on but one of the things
is there's this notion that we have of
rulial space
so we have this idea of this physical
space which is you know something you
can move around in that's that's uh
associated with actual the extent of the
spatial hypergraph then there's what we
call branchial space the space of
quantum branches so in this in this
thing we call the multi-way graph of all
of the sort of branching histories
there's this idea of a kind of space
where instead of moving around in
physical space you're moving from
history to history so to speak from one
possible history to another possible
history and that's kind of a different
kind of space
that is the space in which quantum
mechanics plays out quantum mechanics
like for example oh something like uh i
think we're slowly understanding things
like destructive interference in quantum
mechanics but what's happening is
branchial space is associated with phase
in quantum mechanics and what's
happening is the two photons that are
supposed to be interfering and
destructively destructively interfering
are winding up at different ends of
branchial space and so us as these poor
observers that are trying to that have
branching brains that are trying to
conflate together these different
threads of history and say we've really
got a consistent story that we're
telling here we're really knitting
together these threads of history by the
time the two photons wound up at
opposite ends of branchial space we just
can't knit them together to tell a
consistent story so for us that's sort
of the analog of destructive
interference
got it and then there's rule space too
which is the space of rules yes well
that's that's a another level up so so
there's there's the question um actually
i i do want to mention one thing because
it's something i've realized in recent
times and it's i think it's really
really kind of cool which is about time
dilation and relativity and it kind of
helps to understand it's something that
kind of helps in understanding what's
going on so
in according to relativity if you you
know you have a clock it's ticking at a
certain rate
you send in a spacecraft that's going at
some significant fraction the speed of
light
to you as a observer at rest that clock
that's in the spacecraft will seem to be
ticking much more slowly and so in other
words you know it's kind of like the
the the twin who goes off to alpha
centauri and goes very fast will age
much less than the twin who's on earth
that um that is just hanging out where
they're hanging out okay why does that
happen okay so it has to do with what
motion is
so in in our models of physics
what is motion well when you move from
somewhere to somewhere it's you're
having to sort of recreate yourself at a
different place in space
when you exist at a particular place and
you just evolve with time you're again
you're updating yourself you're you're
following these rules to update what
happens
well so the question is when you have a
certain amount of computation in you so
to speak when there's a certain amount
you know you're computing the universe
is computing at a certain rate you can
either use that computation to work out
sitting still where you are what's going
to happen successively in time or you
can use that computation to recreate
yourself as you move around the universe
and so time dilation ends up being it's
really cool actually that this is
explainable in a in a way that isn't
just imagine the mathematics of
relativity but but um that time dilation
is a story of the fact that as you kind
of are recreating yourself as you move
you are using up some of your
computation and so you don't have as
much computation left over to actually
work out what happens progressively with
time so that means that time is running
more slowly for you because it is
you're you're using up your computation
your your clock can't tick as quickly
because every tick of the clock is using
up some computation but you already use
that computation up on moving at you
know half the speed of light or
something and so that's that's why time
dilation happens
and so you can you can start so it's
kind of interesting that one can sort of
get an intuition about something like
that because it has seemed like just a
mathematical fact about the mathematics
of special relativity and so on well for
me it's a little bit confusing what the
u in that picture is because you're
using up computation
okay so so we're simply saying the
entity is updating itself according to
the way that the universe updates itself
and the question is
your
you know those updates let's imagine the
u is a clock
okay and the clock is you know there's
all these little updates the hypograph
and a sequence of updates caused the
pendulum to swing back the other way and
then swing back swinging back and forth
okay and all of the all of those updates
are contributing to the motion of you
know the pendulum going back and forth
or the oscillator moving whatever it is
okay but but then the alternative is
that's sort of situation one where the
thing is at rest
situation two where it's kind of moving
the the what's happening is it is having
to recreate itself at every at every
moment the thing is going to have to do
the computations to be able to
sort of recreate itself at a different
position in space and that's kind of the
intuition behind so it's either going to
spend its computation recreating itself
at a different position in space or it's
going to spend its computation doing the
um uh sort of doing the updating of the
you know of the the ticking of the clock
so to speak so the more updating is
doing the less the ticking of the clock
update is doing that's right the more it
has having to update because of motion
yeah the less it can update the the
clock so that that's um i mean obviously
there's a there's a sort of mathematical
version of it that relates to how it
actually works in relativity but that's
kind of to me that was sort of exciting
to me that it's possible to have a a
really mechanically explainable story
there that that isn't um and similarly
in quantum mechanics this notion of
branching brains perceiving branching
universes to me that's getting towards a
sort of mechanically explainable version
of what happens in quantum mechanics
even though it's a little bit
mind-bending uh to see you know these
things about under what circumstances
can you successfully knit together those
different threads of history and when do
things sort of escape and and those
kinds of things but the you know the
thing about this physical space and
physical space the the main sort of big
theory is general relativity the theory
of gravity and that tells you how things
move in physical space in bronchial
space the big theory is the feynman path
integral which it turns out tells you
essentially how things move in quantum
in the space of quantum phases so it's
kind of like motion and branchial space
and it's kind of a fun thing to start
thinking about what
oh you know all these things that we
know in physical space like uh event
horizons and black holes and so on what
are the analogous things in branchial
space for example the speed of light
what's the analog of the speed of light
in branch hill space
it's the maximum speed of quantum
entanglement so the speed of light is a
flash bulb goes off here what's the
maximum rate at which the effect of that
flash bulb is detectable moving away in
space
so similarly in bronchial space
something happens and the question is
how far in this branchial space in the
space of quantum states how far away can
that get within a certain period of time
and so there's this notion of a maximum
entanglement speed and that might be
observable that's the thing we've been
sort of poking at is might there be a
way to observe it even in some atomic
physics kind of situation um
because one of the things that's weird
in quantum mechanics is we're you know
when we study quantum mechanics we
mostly study it in terms of small
numbers of particles you know this
electron does this this thing on an ion
trap does that and so on but when we
deal with large numbers of particles
kind of all bets are off it's kind of
too complicated to deal with quantum
mechanics and so what ends up happening
is so this question about maximum
entanglement speed and things like that
may actually play in one of these in the
sort of story of many body quantum
mechanics and even have some suspicions
about
things that might happen even in
one of the things i i realized i'd never
understood and it's kind of embarrassing
but i think i now understand a little
better is when you have chemistry
and you have quantum mechanics
it's like well there's two carbon atoms
there's this molecule and we do a
reaction and we draw a diagram we say
this carbon atom ends up in this place
and it's like but wait a minute in
quantum mechanics nothing ends up in a
definite place there's always just some
wave function for this to happen how can
it be the case that we can draw these
reasonable it just ended up in this
place and you have to kind of say well
the environment of the molecule
effectively made a bunch of measurements
on the molecule to keep it kind of
classical and that's a story that has to
do with this whole thing about about you
know measurements have to do with this
idea of you know can we conclude that
something definite happened because in
quantum mechanics the the intrinsic
quantum mechanics the mathematics of
quantum mechanics is all about they're
just these amplitudes for different
things to happen then there's this thing
of and then we make a measurement and we
conclude that something definite
happened and that has to do with this
thing i think about sort of moving about
knitting together these different
threads of history and saying this is
now something where we can definitively
say something definite happen in the
traditional theory of quantum mechanics
it's just like
you know after you've done all the
sample sheet computation then this big
hammer comes down and you do a
measurement and it's all over and that's
been very confusing for example in
quantum computing it's been a very
confusing thing because when you say you
know in quantum computing the basic idea
is you're going to use all these
separate threads of of computation so to
speak to do all the different parts of
you know try these different factors for
an integer or something like this and it
looks like you can do a lot because
you've got all these different threads
going on but then you have to say well
at the end of it you've got all these
threads and every thread came up with
the definite answer but we've got to
conflate those together to figure out a
definite thing that we humans can take
away from it a definite so the computer
actually produced this output so having
this branchial space and this hypergraph
model of physics do you think it's
possible to then make predictions that
are definite about uh many body quantum
mechanical systems
is that the whole i think it's likely
yes but i don't you know this is every
one of these things when you when you go
from the underlying theory which is
complicated enough and it's i mean the
theory at some level is beautifully
simple but as soon as you start actually
trying to it's this whole question about
how do you bridge it to things that we
humans can talk about it gets really
complicated and and this thing about
actually getting it to a definite
definite prediction um about you know
definite thing you can say about
chemistry or something like this um you
know that's just a lot of work so i'll
give you an example there's a thing
called the quantum zeno effect so
the idea is you know quantum stuff
happens but then if you make a
measurement you're kind of freezing time
in quantum mechanics you and and so it
looks like there's a possibility that
with sort of the the relationship
between the quantum zeno effect and the
way that many body quantum mechanics
works and so on maybe just conceivably
it may be possible to actually figure
out a way to measure the the uh the
maximum entanglement speed and the
reason we can potentially do that is
because the systems we deal with in
terms of atoms and things they're pretty
big you know a mole of atoms is you know
it's a lot of atoms and you know but it
isn't a very you know it's something
where to get you know when we're dealing
with how can you see 10 to the minus 100
so to speak well by the time you've got
you know 10 to the 30th atoms
you're not you know you're within a
little bit closer striking distance of
that it's not like oh we've just got you
know
two atoms and we're trying to see down
to 10 to the minus 100 meters or
whatever so i don't know how it will
work but this is a this is a a potential
direction if you can tell by the way if
we could measure the maximum
entanglement speed we would know the
elementary length these are all related
so if if we get that one number we just
need one number if we can get that one
number we can you know the theory has no
parameters anymore um and uh you know
there are there are other places well
there's another another hope for doing
that is in cosmology uh in this model
one of the features is the universe is
not fixed dimensional i mean we think we
live in three-dimensional space but this
hyper graph doesn't have any particular
dimension it can emerge as something
which on an approximation it's as if you
know you say what's the volume of a
sphere in the hypergraph where a sphere
is defined as how many nodes do you get
to when you go a distance r away from a
given point
and you can say well if i get to about r
cube nodes when i go a distance r away
in the hypergraph then i'm living
roughly in three dimensional space but
you might also get to r to the point you
know 2.92
you know for for some value for r in you
know as as our increases that might be
the the sort of fit to what happens and
so one of the things we suspect is that
the very early universe was essentially
infinite dimensional and that as the
universe
expanded it became lower dimensional and
so one of the things that is another
little sort of point where we we think
there might be a way to to actually
measure some things is dimension
fluctuations in the early universe that
is is there a is there leftover
dimension fluctuation of at the time of
the cosmic microwave background 100 000
years or something after the beginning
of the universe is it still the case
that there are there were pieces of the
universe that didn't have dimension 3
that had dimension 3.01 or something and
can we tell that is that possible to
observe
uh
the fluctuations in dimensions i don't
even know what that entails okay so the
the question
which should be an elementary exercise
in electrodynamics except it isn't is um
understanding what happens to a photon
when it propagates through 3.01
dimensional space
so for example the inverse square law is
a consequence of the you know the the
surface area of a sphere is proportional
to r squared
but if you're not in three dimensional
space the surface area of sphere is not
proportional to r squared it's r to the
whatever 2.01 or something
and so that means that
i think when you kind try and do optics
you know a common principle in optics is
huygens principle which basically says
that every piece of a wavefront of a of
a
of light is a source of new spherical
waves and those spherical waves if
they're different dimensional spherical
waves will have other characteristics
and so there will be bizarre optical
phenomena which we haven't figured out
yet um so you're you're you're what
looking for some weird photon
trajectories
that designate that it's 3.01
dimensional space yeah
yeah that would be an example of i mean
you know there are there are only a
certain number of things we can measure
about photons you know we can measure
their polarization we can measure their
frequency we can measure their direction
um those kinds of things and you know
how that all works out
and you know in the current models of
physics uh you know it's been hard to
explain how the universe manages to be
as uniform as it is and that's led to
this inflation idea that um to the to
the great annoyance of my then
collaborator i we had we figured out in
like 1979 we had this realization that
that you could get something like this
but it seemed implausible that that's
the way the universe worked so we put in
a footnote and that was uh so that's a
but but any case i i've never really
completely believed it but this that's
an idea for how to sort of puff out the
universe faster than the speed of light
early moments of the universe that
that's the sort of inflation idea and
that you can somehow explain how the
universe manages to be as uniform as it
is in in our model this turns out to be
much more natural because the universe
just starts very connected the
hypergraph is not
such that the ball that you grow
starting from single point has volume r
cubed it might have volume r to the 500
or r to the infinity um and so that
means that you you sort of naturally get
this much higher degree of connectivity
and uniformity in the universe and then
the question is uh this is sort of the
mathematical physics challenge is in the
standard theory of the universe there's
the friedman robertson walker universe
which is the kind of standard model
where the universe is isotropic and
homogeneous and you can then work out
the equations of general relativity and
you can figure out how the universe
expands
we would like to do the same kind of
thing including dimension change
this is just difficult mathematical
physics i mean the reason it's difficult
is there's sort of fundamental reason
it's difficult when when people invented
calculus 300 years ago calculus was a
story of understanding
change and change as a function of a
variable so people study univariate
calculus they study multivariate
calculus it's one variable it's two
variables three variables but whoever
studied you know 2.5 variable calculus
turns out nobody turns out that but what
we need to have to understand these
fractional dimensional spaces uh which
don't work like well they're
they're spaces where where the effective
dimension is not an integer so you can't
apply the tools of calculus in naturally
and easily to fractional dimensions no
so somebody has to figure out how to do
that yeah we're trying to figure this
out i mean it's it's very interesting
it's very connected to very frontier
issues in mathematics it's very
beautiful but so is it possible is it
possible we're dealing with a scale
that's so so much smaller than our human
scale
is it possible to make predictions
versus explanations do you have a hope
that with this hypograph model you'll be
able to make predictions yeah
that
that could be validated with a physics
experiment predictions that couldn't
have been done or weren't done otherwise
oh yeah yeah i mean you know i think
which in which domain do you think okay
so they're going to be cosmology ones to
do with dimension fluctuations in the
universe that's a very bizarre effect
nobody you know dimension fluctuation is
just something nobody ever looked for
that if anybody sees dimension
fluctuation that's a huge flag that
something like our model is going on if
and and how one detects that you know
that's a problem of kind of you know
that's a problem of traditional physics
in a sense of what's the best way to
actually
figure that out and and for example that
that's one there are there are all kinds
of things one can imagine i mean there
are things that um uh in black hole
mergers it's possible that there will be
effects of maximum entanglement speed
and large black hole mergers um that's
another another possible thing and all
of that is detected through like what do
you have a hope for ligo type of
situation like gravitational waves yeah
or alternatively i mean i think it's you
know
look figuring out experiments is like
figuring out technology inventions right
that is you know you've got a set of raw
materials you've got an underlying model
and now you've got to be very clever to
figure out you know what is that thing i
can measure that just somehow you know
leverages in to the right place and
we've spent less effort on that than i
would have liked because i one of the
one of the reasons is that that i think
that the the this you know the
physicists who've been working on on our
models we've with now lots of physicists
actually it's very very nice it's kind
of uh
it's one of these cases where i'm almost
i'm really kind of pleasantly surprised
that the sort of absorption of the
things we've done has been uh quite
rapid and quite uh sort of you know very
positive so it's a cambrian explosion of
physicists too not just ideas
yes i mean you know a lot of what's
happened that's really interesting and
again not what i expected is there are a
lot of areas of of sort of very uh
elaborate sophisticated mathematical
physics
whether that's causal set theory whether
it's higher category theory whether it's
categorical quantum mechanics all sorts
of elaborate names for these things spin
networks perhaps uh you know causal
dynamical triangulations all kinds of
names of these fields and these fields
have a bunch of good mathematical
physicists in them who've been working
for decades in these particular areas
and the question is but but they've been
building these mathematical structures
and the mathematical structures are
interesting but they're not they don't
typically sit on anything they're just
mathematical structures and i think
what's happened is our models provide
kind of a machine code that lives
underneath those models so a typical
example this is uh uh due to jonathan
gorad who's one of the key people who's
been working on our project um this is
uh in okay so i'll give you an example
just to give a sense of how these things
connect this is in causal set theory so
the idea of causal set theory is
there are in space-time we imagine that
there's space and time it's a three plus
one-dimensional you know set up we
imagine that there are just events that
happen at different times and places in
space and time
and the idea of causal set theory is the
only thing you say about the universe is
there are a bunch of events that happen
sort of randomly at different places in
space and time and then the whole sort
of theory of physics has to be to do
with this this graph of causal
relationships between these randomly
thrown down events
so they've always been confused by the
fact that to get even lorentz and
variance even relativistic and variants
you need a very special way to throw
down those events and they've had no
natural way to understand how that would
happen
so what jonathan figured out is that in
fact from our models
they instead of just
generating events at random our models
necessarily generate events in some
pattern in space-time effectively that
then leads to ransom variants and
relativistic invariants and all those
kinds of things so it's a place where
all the mathematics that's been done on
well we just have a random collection of
events now what you know what
consequences does that have in terms of
causal set theory and so on that can all
be kind of wheeled in now that we have
some different underlying foundational
idea for what what the particular
distribution of events is as opposed to
just we throw down random events
and so that's a that's a typical sort of
example of what we're seeing in all
these different areas of kind of how you
can take you know really interesting
things that have been done in
mathematical physics and connect them
and it's really kind of beautiful
because the the you know the sort of the
abstract models we have just seem to
plug into all these different very
interesting very elegant abstract ideas
but we're now giving sort of a reason
for that to be the way
for for a reason for one to care i mean
it's like saying
uh you can you know you can think about
computation abstractly you know you can
think about i don't know combinators or
something as abstract computational
things and you can sort of do all kinds
of study of them but it's like why do we
care well okay turing machines are a
good start because you can kind of see
they're sort of mechanically doing
things but when we actually start
thinking about computers computing
things we have a really good reason to
care and this is sort of what we're what
we're providing i think is a reason to
care about a lot of these areas of
mathematical physics so that's been
that's been very nice so i'm not sure
we've ever got to the
the question of why does the university
let's let's let's talk about that yes so
we're it's not the simplest question in
the world so um so it's it takes a few
steps to get to it and it's nevertheless
even surprisingly you can even begin to
answer this question indeed as you were
saying i'm very surprised
so
the next thing to perhaps understand is
this idea of rulial space
so we've got kind of physical space
we've got branchial space the space of
possible quantum histories and now we've
got another level of kind of abstraction
which is real space and here's the
here's where that comes from
so you say okay you say we've got this
model for the universe we've got
a particular rule and we run this rule
and we get the universe okay so that's
that's interesting why that rule why not
another rule
and so that confused me for a long time
then i realized well actually
what if
the thing could be using all possible
rules what if at every step in addition
to saying apply a particular rule at all
places in this hyper graph one could say
just take all possible rules and apply
all possible rules at all possible
places in this hypergraph
okay and then you make this rulial
multi-way graph which both is all
possible histories for a particular rule
and all possible rules so the next thing
you'd say is how can you get anything
reasonable how can anything you know
real come out of the set of all possible
rules applied in all possible ways okay
there's a subtle thing so which i
haven't fully untangled
the there is this object which is the
result of running all possible rules in
all possible ways and you might say if
you're running all possible rules why
can't everything possible happen
well the answer is because
when you there's sort of this
entanglement that occurs so let's say
that you have a lot of different
possible initial conditions a lot of
different possible states then you're
applying these different rules
well some of those rules can end up with
the same state so it isn't the case that
you can just get from anywhere to
anywhere there's this whole entangled
structure of what can lead to what and
there's a definite structure that's
produced
i think i'm going to call that definite
structure the ruliad the limit of um
the limits of kind of uh all possible
rules being applied in all possible ways
and you're saying that structure is
finite
so that somehow connects to maybe a
similar kind of thing as like causal
invariance well there happens
necessarily has causal invariance that's
a feature of that's just a mathematical
consequence of essentially using all
possible rules plus universal
computation gives you the fact that from
any diverging paths you can always the
the paths will always convert does that
say that the rule does that necessarily
infer that the ruliad is
finite
in the end it's not necessarily finite i
mean it's it's a it's a the the just
like the history of the universe may not
be finite the history of the universe
time may keep going forever you can keep
running the computations of the ruliad
and you'll keep spewing out more and
more and more structure it's like time
doesn't have to end
it's it's um
that but the the issue is there are
there are three limits that happen in
this ruliad object
one is how long you run the computation
for another is how many different rules
you're applying and another is how many
different states you start from
and the mixture of those three limits i
mean this is just mathematically a
horrendous object okay and what's what's
interesting about this object is the one
thing that does seem to be the case
about this object is it connects with
ideas in higher category theory and in
particular it connects to some of the
20th century's most abstract mathematics
done by this chap growth indeek
growth and leak had a thing called the
infinity group void which is closely
related to this roulette object
although the details of the relationship
uh you know i don't fully understand yet
um but i think that the what's what's
interesting is this thing that is sort
of this very limiting object so so okay
so a way to think about this that that
again will will take us into another
direction which is the equivalence
between physics and mathematics
the way that uh
well let's see uh maybe this is um just
to give a sense of this kind of um
groupoid and things like that you can
think about in mathematics you can think
you have certain axioms they're kind of
like atoms and you well actually let's
say
let's talk about mathematics for a
second so what is mathematics what do
what is what is it made of so to speak
mathematics there's a bunch of
statements like uh
for addition x plus y is equal to y plus
x that's a statement of mathematics
another statement will be you know x
squared minus one is equal to x plus one
x minus one there are infinite number of
these possible statements of mathematics
well it's not i mean it's not just i
guess a statement but with x plus y it's
uh it's a rule the you can it's a i mean
you think of it as a rule it's it's a it
is a it is a rule it's also just a thing
that is true in mathematics right um the
statement of truth okay right and and
what you can imagine is you you you
imagine just laying out this giant kind
of ocean of all all statements well
actually you first start okay this is
where
this was segwaying into a different
thing let me let me not go in this
direction for a second let's not go to
meta mathematics just yet yeah we'll
we'll maybe get to meta mathematics but
it's it's um uh so let me not let me
explain the groupoid and things later
yes yeah but but so let's come back to
the universe um always a good place to
be in so yeah so what does the universe
have to do with the rouley ad the rulio
space and how that's possible
lee connected to why the thing exists at
all and why there's just one of them yes
okay so here's the point so the thing
that had confused me for a long time was
let's say we get the rule for the
universe we hold it in our hand we say
this is our universe then the immediate
question is well why isn't another one
and you know that's kind of the you know
the the sort of the lesson of copernicus
is we're not very special so how come we
got universe number 312 and not universe
quadrillion quadrillion quadrillion and
i think the resolution of that is the
realization that
there that the universe is running all
possible rules
so then you say well how on earth do we
perceive the universe to be running
according to a particular rule how do we
perceive definite things happening in
the universe well
it's the same story it's the observer
there is a reference frame that we are
picking in this rule space
and that that is what determines our
perception of the universe with our
particular sensory information and so on
we are parsing the universe in this
particular way so here's the way to
think about it in in in physical space
we live in a particular place in the
universe and you know we could live in
alpha centauri but we don't we live here
um and
similarly in rural space
we could live in many different places
in rural space but we happen to live
here and what does it mean to live here
it means we have certain sensory input
we have certain ways to parse the
universe
those are our interpretation of the
universe what would it mean to travel in
rule space
what it basically means is that we are
successively interpreting the universe
in different ways so in other words to
be at a different point in rule space is
to have a different in a sense a
different interpretation of what's going
on in the universe and we can imagine
even things like an analog of the speed
of light as the maximum speed of
translation in real space and so on
so wait what's the
interpretation
so real space
and we is i'm confused by the we and the
interpretation and the universe i
thought moving about in real space
changes the way the universe
is
is
the the way we would perceive it the way
that so this ultimately has to do with
the perception so it doesn't real real
space is not
somehow changing
like
uh
branching into another universe
something like that no i mean
the point is that the whole point of
this is the rouliad is
sort of
the encapsulated version of everything
that is the universe running according
to all possible yeah we think of uh our
universe the observable universe
as its
thing so we're a little bit loose with
the word universe then because wouldn't
the ruley ad
potentially encapsulate
a very large number like combinatorially
large maybe infinite
set of what we
human physicists think of as universes
that's an interesting interesting
parsing of the word universe right
because what we're saying is just as
we're at a particular place in physical
space we're at a particular place in
rural space
at that particular place in rural space
our experience of the universe is this
yeah just as if we lived at the center
of the galaxy our universe our
experience of the universe will be
different from the when it is given
where we actually live and so in us what
we're saying is our
when you might say i mean in a sense
this this ruliad is sort of a super
universe so to speak um but it's all
entangled together it's not like you can
separate out you can say let me
it's it's like when we take a reference
okay it's like our experience of the
universe is based on where we are in the
universe
we could imagine moving to somewhere
else in the universe but it's still the
same universe so there's not like
universes
existing in parallel
no
because because
and the whole point is that if we were
able to change our interpretation of
what's going on
we could perceive a different reference
frame in this roulette yeah but that's
not
that's not uh that's just yeah that's
the same rule yeah that's the same
universe you're just moving about this
is just coordinates right so so the way
that's the reason that's interesting is
imagine the extraterrestrial
intelligence so the alien intelligence
we should say
the alien intelligence might live on
alpha centauri but it might also live at
a different place in rural space it can
live right here on earth it just has a
different reference frame that
includes a very different perception of
the universe right and then because that
really all space is very large
i mean
do we get to communicate with them right
that's yeah but it's also well one uh
thing is how
different the perception
of the universe could be i think it
could be bizarrely
unimaginably completely different and i
mean one thing to realize is even in
kind of things i don't understand well
you know i'm i i know about the kind of
western tradition of understanding you
know science and all that kind of thing
and you know you talk to people who say
well i you know i'm really into some you
know eastern tradition of this that and
the other and it's really obvious to me
what how things work
i don't understand it at all
but you know it is not obvious i think
with this kind of realization that
there's these very different ways to
interpret what's going on in the
universe that kind of gives me at least
it doesn't help me to understand that
different interpretation but it gives me
at least more respect for the
possibility that there will be other
interpretations yeah it humbles you to
the possibility that like what is it
reincarnation or all all these like uh
eternal recurrence with nietzsche like
just these ideas
yeah
well you know the thing that i realized
about a bunch of those things is that
you know i've been sort of doing my
little survey of the history of
philosophy just trying to understand you
know what what can i actually say now
about some of these things and you
realize that some of these concepts like
the immortal soul concept
which you know i remember when i was a
kid and you know it was kind of a lots
of religion bashing type stuff of people
saying you know what we know about
physics tell us how much does a soul
weigh
and people are like well how can it be a
thing if it doesn't weigh anything
well now we understand you know there is
this notion of what's in brains that
isn't the matter of brains and it's
something computational and there is a
sense and in fact it is correct that it
is in some sense immortal because this
pattern of computation is something
abstract that is not specific to the
particular material of a brain now we
don't know how to extract it you know in
our traditional scientific approach but
it's still something where it isn't a
crazy thing to say there is something it
doesn't weigh anything that's a kind of
a silly question how much does it weigh
um well actually maybe it isn't such a
silly question in our model of physics
because the actual computational
activity has has a consequence for
gravity and things but that's a very
very subtle because if we start talking
about mass and energy and so on there
could be a uh what would you call a
solatron
yes yes yes a particle
that somehow contains soulness yeah
right well that's what by the way that's
what leibniz said and you know one thing
i've i've never understood this you know
leibniz had the center of monads and
monadolology and he had this idea that
that what exists in the universe is this
big collection of monads and that they
that the only thing that one knows about
the monads is sort of how they relate to
each other which sounds awfully like
hypographs right but leibniz had really
lost me at the following thing he said
each of these monads has a soul and each
of them has a consciousness
and it's like okay i'm out of here i
don't understand this at all i don't
know what's going on but i realized
recently that in his day the concept
that a thing could do something could
spontaneously do something that was his
only way of describing that
and so what i would now say is well as
this abstract rule that runs to leibniz
that would have been you know in 1690 or
whatever that would have been kind of
well it has a soul it has a
consciousness um and so you know in a
sense it's it's like one of these
there's no new idea under the sun so to
speak that's you know that's a sort of a
version of of the same kinds of ideas
but couched in terms that are sort of
bizarrely different from the ones that
we would use today would you be able to
maybe play devil's advocate on the your
conception of consciousness that uh like
the the two characteristics of it that
is constrained and there's a
single thread of time is it possible the
liveness was onto something that
the the basic atom the screw atom of
space has a consciousness
is is that uh so these are just words
right but yeah
what is there is there some sense where
consciousness is much more fundamental
than you're making it seem i don't know
i mean that you know i think can you
construct a world in which it is much
more fundamental
i think that okay so the question would
be
is there a way to think about kind of uh
if we sort of parse the universe down at
the level of atoms of space or something
could we say well so that's really a
question of a different point of view a
different place in real space we're
asking you're asking the question could
there be a civilization that exists
could there be sort of uh conscious
entities that exist at the level of
atoms of space and what would that be
like and i think that comes back to this
question of can we you know what's it
like to be a cellular automaton type
thing um i mean it's it's you know i'm
i'm not yet there i don't know i mean i
think that the this is a and i don't
even know
yet quite how to think about this in the
sense that i was considering you know
i'm i never write fiction but i i
haven't written it since i was like 10
years old my my fiction i made one
attempt which i sent to some science
fiction writer friends of mine and they
told me it was terrible so
but um this is a long time ago no it was
recently recently they said it was
terrible that'd be interesting to see
you write a short story based on what
sounds like it's already inspiring short
stories by or stories yeah right science
fiction writers but but i think the the
interesting thing for me is
you know in the what does it what is it
like to be a whatever yeah how do you
describe that i mean it's like that's
not a thing that you describe in
mathematics that what is it like to be
such and such well see to me
when you say what is it like to be
something
presumes that you're talking about
a singular entity
so
yeah
like there there's a some kind of
feeling of the the entity
the the stuff that's inside of it and
the stuff that's outside of it
and then
that's when consciousness starts making
sense
but but then um
it seems like that could be
generalizable if you take some subset
of uh a cellular automata you could
start talking about what does that
subset
maybe a few but then you can i think you
could just take arbitrary
numbers of subsets like
to me uh uh like you and i
uh individually are consciousnesses but
you could also say the two of us
together is a singular consciousness
maybe maybe i'm not so sure about that i
think that the single thread of time
thing may be pretty important and that
as soon as you start saying there are
two different threads of time there are
two different experiences and then we
have to say how do they relate how are
they sort of entangled with each other i
mean that may be a different story of a
thing that isn't much like you know the
the what do the ants you know what's it
like to be an ant you know where there's
a sort of more collective view of the
world so to speak i don't know i think
that um i mean this is uh uh
you know
i don't really have a good i mean you
know my best thought is you know can we
turn it into a human story it's like the
question of you know when we try and
understand physics can we turn that into
something which is sort of a human
understandable narrative and now what's
it like to be a such and such you know
maybe the only medium in which we can
describe that is something like fiction
where it's kind of like you're telling
you know the life story in that in that
uh in that setting but i i'm this is
this is beyond what i've what i've yet
understood how to do yeah but it does
seem so like with human consciousness
you know we're made up of cells and like
there's a bunch of systems that are
networked
that work together that at this at the
human level
feel like a singular consciousness when
you take yes
and so maybe like an ant colony is just
too low level
sorry an ant is too low level right
maybe you have to look at the ant colony
yeah i agree like there's some level at
which
it's a conscious being and then if you
go to the planetary scale then maybe
that's going too far so there's a nice
sweet spot yeah right consciousness no i
mean i agree i think i think the
difficulty is that
you know
okay so in sort of people who talk about
consciousness yes one of the one of the
terrible things i've realized because
i've now interacted with with some of
this community so to speak some
interesting people who do that kind of
thinking but you know one of the things
i was saying to one of the leading
people in that area i was saying you
know uh
that um you know it must be kind of
frustrating because it's kind of like a
poetry story that is many people are
writing poems but few people are reading
them yes so there are always these
different you know everybody has their
own theory of consciousness and they are
very non-inter sort of interdiscussible
and and by the way i mean you know my
own approach to sort of the the question
of consciousness as far as i'm concerned
i'm an applied consciousness operative
so to speak because i don't really in a
sense the thing i'm trying to get out of
it is how does it help me to understand
what's a possible theory of physics and
how does it help me to say how do i go
from this this incoherent collection of
things happening in the universe
to our definite perception and definite
laws and so on and sort of an applied
version of consciousness and and i think
the reason it sort of segues to a
different kind of topic but the reason
that um uh one of the things i'm
particularly interested in is kind of
what's the analog of consciousness and
systems very different from brains
and so why does that matter
well you know this whole description of
this kind of uh
well i should you know what we haven't
talked about why the universe exists so
let's let's get to why the universe
exists and then we then we can can talk
about perhaps a little bit about what
these models of physics kind of show you
about other kinds of things like
molecular computing and so on yes but
that's okay that's good why does the
universe exist okay so we finally sort
of more or less set the stage we've got
this idea of this ruliad of this object
that is made from following all possible
rules the fact that it's sort of not
just this incoherent mess it's got all
this entangled structure in it and so on
okay so what is this ruliad well it is
the working out of all possible formal
systems so the the sort of the question
of why does the universe exist its core
question which kind of started with is
you've got two plus two equals four
you've got some other abstract results
but that's not actualized it's just an
abstract thing and when we say we've got
a model for the universe okay it's this
rule you run it and it'll make the
universe but it's like but but
you know where's it actually running
what what what is what is it actually
doing right what is is it actual or is
it merely a formal description of
something okay
so the thing to realize with this with
this the the thing about the rouliad is
it's an inevitable it is
the entangled running of all possible
rules so you don't get to say it's not
like you're saying which roulette are
you picking because it's all possible
formal rules it's not like it's just um
you know well actually it's only
footnote the only footnote it's an
important footnote is it's all possible
computational rules
not hyper-computational rules that is
it's running all the rules
that would be
accessible to a turing machine
but it is not running all the rules that
will be accessible to a thing that can
solve problems in finite time that would
take a turing machine infinite time to
solve so you can even alan turing knew
this that you could make oracles for
touring machines where you say a touring
machine can't solve the whole thing
problem for touring machines it can't
know what will happen in any touring
machine after an infinite time in any
finite time but you could invent a box
just make a black box you say i'm going
to sell you an oracle that will just
tell you you know press this button
it'll tell you what the touring machine
will do after an infinite time you can
imagine such a box you can't necessarily
build one in the physical universe but
you can imagine such a box and so we
could say well in addition to so in this
ruliad we're imagining that there is a
computational that at the end it's it's
running rules that are computational it
doesn't have a bunch of uh oracle black
boxes in it you say well why not well
turns out if there are oracle black
boxes the ruliad that is you can make a
sort of super rouliad that contains
those oracle black boxes but it has a
cosmological event horizon relative to
the first one they can't communicate
in other words you can you can end up
with what you end up happening what ends
up happening is it's it's like in the
physical universe we in this causal
graph that represents the causal
relationships of different things you
can have an event horizon where there's
where the causal graph is disconnected
where the effect here an event happening
here does not affect an event happening
here because there's a disconnection in
the causal graph and that's what happens
at an event horizon and so the what will
happen between this kind of the ordinary
ruliad and the hyper ruliad is there is
an event horizon and you you know we in
our rouliad will just never know
that there is that they're just separate
things they're not they're not connected
maybe i'm not understanding but just
because we can't observe it
uh why does that mean it doesn't exist
um
it might exist but it does it's not
clear what it it's so what so to speak
whether it exists i mean you know what
we're trying to understand is why does
our universe exist
we're not trying to ask the question
what uh you know it's
let me say another thing let me make a
meta comment okay which is that that i
have not thought through this hyper
really ad business properly so i'm i'm i
can't the the the the the the hyper
ruliad is referring to
a ruliad in which hyper computation is
possible that's correct okay so like
what the that footnote
the footnote to the footnote
is we're not
sure why
this is important yeah that's right so
let's let's ignore that okay it's
already abstract enough okay so so okay
so the the one question is
we have to say if we're saying why does
the universe exist one question is why
is it this universe and not another
universe yeah okay
so the the important point about this
ruliad idea is that
it's in the rouliad are all possible
formal systems so there's no choice
being made there's no there's no like oh
we picked this particular universe and
not that one that's the first thing the
second thing is the that we have to ask
the question so so you say why does 2
plus 2 equals 4 exist
that's not really a that is a thing that
necessarily is that way
just on the basis of the meaning of the
terms 2 and plus and equals and so on
right so the thing is that this this
ruliad object is in a sense a necessary
object it is just the thing that is the
consequence of working out the
consequence of the formal definition of
things you don't it is not a thing where
you're saying and this is picked as the
particular thing this is just something
which necessarily
is
that thing because of the definition of
what it means to have computations is
there really a it's a formal system
yes
but does it exist
ah
well
uh where are we in this whole thing
we are part of this ruliad and so our so
there is no sense to say does two plus
two equals four exist
well that's that's in some sense it
necessarily exists it's a necessary
object it's not a thing that where you
can ask
uh you know it's it's usually in in
philosophy there's a sort of distinction
made between uh you know necessary
truths contingent truths analytic
propositions synthetic propositions
there are a variety of different
versions of this they're things which
are necessarily true just based on the
definition of terms and there are things
which happen to be true in our universe
but
we're we don't exist in rural space we
that's one of the coordinates that
define our existence
right
well okay so so yes yes but this ruliad
is the set of all possible rule
coordinates so what we're saying is it
contains that so what we're saying is we
exist
as okay so our perception of what's
going on is we're at a particular place
in this ruling ad and we are concluding
certain things about how the universe
works based on that
but the question is do we understand you
know
is there something where we say
so so why does it work that way
well the answer is i think it has to
work that way because
this
there isn't this ruliad is a necessary
object in the sense that it is a purely
formal object just like two plus two
equals four it's not an object that was
made of something it's an object that is
just an expression of the necessary
collection of formal relations that
exist
and so then the issue is
can we
in our experience of that
is it you know can we have tables and
chairs so to speak in
that just by virtue of our experience of
that necessary thing
and you know what people have generally
thought and honestly that i don't know
of a lot of
discussion of this why does the universe
exist question it's been a very
you know i've been surprised actually at
how little
i mean i think it's one of these things
that's really uh kind of far out there
but the thing that that is you know the
surprise here is that
all possible formal rules when you run
them together and that's the critical
thing when you run them together they
produce this kind of entangled structure
that has a definite structure it's not
just
a you know a random arbitrary thing it's
a thing with definite structure and that
structure is the thing when we are
embedded in that structure when when
anything you know the an entity embedded
in that structure perceives something
which is
then we can interpret as physics and
things like this
so in other words we don't have to ask
the question the the the why does it
exist it necessarily exists i'm missing
this part why does it necessarily exist
okay okay so like you need to have it if
you want to formalize the relation
between entities but why
[Music]
why do you need to have relations okay
okay so so let's say
you say um
well
it's like why does math have to exist
okay that's the same question yeah okay
fair question
um
let's see i think the thing to think
about is
the existence of mathematics is
something where
given a definition of terms
what follows from that definition
inevitably follows
so now you can say
why define any terms
but in a sense the
well that's okay so the the definition
of terms
i mean i think the way to think about
this let me see so like
concrete terms
i mean they're just things like you know
uh
logical or
right that's a thing
that's a powerful thing well it's a it's
a yes okay but it's it's a
the point is that it is not a thing
about you know people imagine
there is i don't know
the uh uh you know an elephant or
something or the you know elephants are
presumably not necessary objects they
are they happen to exist as a result of
kind of biological evolution and
whatever else
but the the thing is that
in some sense that there is it is a
different kind of thing to say does plus
exist
the the it's not it's not not like an
elephant so a plus is seems more
fundamental more basic than an elephant
yes but
you can imagine
a world without
plus or anything like it like why do
formal things that are discreet
that can be used
to reason have to exist or uh well okay
so why okay so that then the question is
but the whole point is computation we
can certainly imagine computation that
is we can certainly say there is a
formal system that we can construct
abstractly in our minds that is
computation
and that
that's the um uh and you know we can we
can imagine it right now the question is
um is it is
that formal system
once we exist as observers embedded in
that formal system that's enough to have
something which is like our universe
yeah and so then the then what you're
kind of asking is perhaps
is
why
i mean the point is we definitely can
imagine it there's nothing that says
that we're not saying
that
there's it's sort of inevitable that
that
is a thing that we can imagine we don't
have to ask does it exist
we're just it is definitely something we
can imagine
now that's then we have this thing that
is a formally constructable thing that
we can imagine and now we have to ask
the question
what you know given that formally
constructable thing
what is uh what consequences does that
if we were to perceive that formally if
we were embedded in that formally
constructable thing what would be
perceived about the world and we would
say we perceive that the world exists
because we are we are seeing all of this
mechanism of all these things happening
and but that's something that is just a
feature of it's it's it's something
where we are
see another way of asking this that i'm
trying to get at
i understand why it feels like
this uh
rooliad is
necessary
but maybe it's just me being human but
it feels like then you should be able to
not us but somehow step outside of the
roulette
like what's outside the roulette
well the ruling out is all formal
systems
so there's nothing because but that's
what a human would say i know that's
what a human would say because we're
used to the idea that there are there's
but the whole point is that by the time
it's all possible formal systems
it's it's like it is all things you can
imagine but not all computations you can
imagine
but like we don't
well so what we don't see that could be
other code okay so so that's a that's a
fair question is it possible to encode
uh all i mean once we is is there
something that isn't what we can
represent formally right that is that is
there's something that um and that's i
think related to the hyper rouliad
footnote so to speak
you know one of the things sort of
interesting about this is
you know there has been some discussion
of this in theology and things like that
um but uh which i don't necessarily
understand all of um but the the key
sort of new input is this idea that all
possible formal systems it's like you
know if you make a world people say well
you make a world with a particular in a
particular way with particular rules but
no you don't do that you can make a
world that deals with all possible rules
and then merely by virtue of living in a
particular place in that world so to
speak we have the perception we have of
what the world is like
now i have to say the the um uh it's
sort of interesting because i i've you
know i wrote this piece about this and i
i you know this philosophy stuff is not
super easy and i i've
um i as i'm as i'm talking to you about
it and i actually haven't you know
people have been interested in lots of
different things we've been doing but
this why does the universe exist has
been i would say one of the one of the
ones that you would think people will be
most interested in but actually i think
they're just like oh that's just
something complicated that that um so so
i haven't i haven't explained it as as
much as i've explained a bunch of other
things and i have to say i think i i
think i may be missing a couple of
pieces of that argument that um uh would
be so so it's kind of a like well your
your uh conscious being is
computationally bounded so you're
missing having written quite a few
articles yourself you you're now missing
some of the pieces yes
being human right
one of the consequences of this why the
unit why the universe exists thing and
this kind of concept of
ruling ads and and uh you know places in
there representing our perception of the
universe and so on one of the weird
consequences is
if the universe exists mathematics must
also exist
and that's a weird thing because
mathematics people have been very
confused including me have been very
confused about
the the question of of kind of what
uh what is the foundation of mathematics
what is what kind of a thing is
mathematics is mathematics
something where we just write down
axioms like euclid did for geometry and
we just build the structure and we could
have written down different axioms and
we'd have a different structure or is it
something that has a more fundamental
sort of truth to it and i have to say
it's one of these cases where i've i've
long believed that mathematics has a
great deal of arbitrariness to it that
there are particular axioms that kind of
got written down by the babylonians and
uh you know that's what we've ended up
with the mathematics that we have and i
have to say actually my my wife has been
telling me for 25 years she's a
mathematician she's been telling me
you're wrong about the foundations of
mathematics and and you know i'm like no
no no i know what i'm talking about and
finally
she's she's much more right than i've
been so it's um it's wonderful so i mean
uh her sense
in your sense are we just uh so this is
to the question of uh meta mathematics
so we're just
kind of on the trajectory through
rule space except in mathematics through
a trajectory a certain kind of
thing that's partly the idea so so i
think that the notion is this so 100
years ago a little bit more than 100
years ago but people have been doing
mathematics for ages but then in the in
the late 1800s people decided to try and
formalize mathematics and say you know
it is mathematics is you know we're
going to break it down we're going to
make it like logic we're going to make
it out of out of sort of fundamental
primitives and that was people like
fraga and piano and hilbert and so on
and they kind of got this idea of let's
do kind of euclid but even better let's
just make everything just in terms of
this sort of symbolic axioms and then
build up mathematics from that
and that you know they thought at the
time as soon as they get
these symbolic axioms that they made the
same mistake the kind of computational
irreducibility mistake they thought as
soon as we've written down the axioms
then it'll just we'll just have a
machine
kind of a super mathematica so to speak
that can just grind out all true
theorems of mathematics
that got exploited by godel's theorem
which is basically the story of
computational irreducibility it's that
even though you know those underlying
rules you can't deduce all the
consequences in any finite way
and so so that was but now the question
is okay so they broke mathematics down
into these axioms and they say now you
build up from that
so what i'm increasingly uh coming to
realize is that's similar to saying
let's take a gas and break it down into
molecules
there's gas laws that are the
large-scale structure and so on that we
humans are familiar with and then
there's the underlying molecular
dynamics and i think that the axiomatic
level of mathematics which we can access
with automated theorem proving and proof
assistance and these kinds of things
that's the molecular dynamics of
mathematics and occasionally we see
through to that molecular dynamics we
see undecidability we see other things
like this one things i've always found
very mysterious is that godel's theorem
shows that there are
sort of things which cannot be finitely
proved in mathematics there are proofs
of arbitrary length infinite length
proofs that you might need
but in practical mathematics
mathematicians don't typically run into
this they just happily go along doing
their mathematics and i think what's
actually happening is that what they're
doing is they're looking at
this they are essentially observers
in
meta mathematical space
and they are picking a reference frame
in metal mathematical space and they are
computationally bounded observers in
metamathematical space which is causing
them to deduce that the laws of
metamathematics and the laws of
mathematics like the laws of fluid
mechanics are much more understandable
than this underlying molecular dynamics
and so what gets really bizarre is
thinking about kind of the analogy
between matter mathematics this idea of
of you exist in this kind of uh um
in the sort of space of possible um in
this kind of mathematical space where
the where the individual kind of uh
points in the mathematical space are
statements in mathematics and they're
connected by proofs where one statement
you know you take a couple of different
statements you can use those to prove
some other statement and you've got this
whole network of proofs that's the kind
of causal network of mathematics so what
can prove what and so on and you can say
at any moment in the history of a
mathematician of a single mathematical
consciousness you are in a single kind
of slice
of this kind of meta-mathematical space
you you know a certain set of
mathematical statements you can then
deduce with proofs you can deduce other
ones and so on you're kind of gradually
moving through meta-mathematical space
and so it's kind of the view is that the
reason that mathematicians perceive
mathematics to have the sort of
integrity and lack of kind of
undecidability and so on that they do is
because they like we as as observers of
the physical universe we have these
limitations associated with
computational boundedness single thread
of time consciousness limitations
basically that the same thing is true of
mathematicians perceiving sort of
meta-mathematical space and so what's
happening is that when you look at if
you look at one of these formalized
mathematics systems something like you
know pythagoras theorem it'll be it'll
take oh i don't know
uh what is it maybe 10 000 individual
little steps to prove pythagoras's
theorem and one of the bizarre things
that's a sort of an empirical fact that
i'm trying to understand a little bit
better if you look at different proof
assists if you look at different
formalized mathematics systems they
actually have different axioms
underneath but they can all prove
pythagoras theorem and so in other words
it's a little bit like what happens with
gases we can have air molecules we can
have water molecules but they still have
fluid dynamics both of them have fluid
dynamics and so similarly at the level
that mathematics that mathematicians
care about mathematics it's way above
the macular dynamics so to speak
and there are all kinds of weird things
like for example one thing i was
realizing recently is that the quantum
theory of mathematics that's a very
bizarre idea but um basically when you
prove
what is you know a proof
is you've got one statement in
mathematics you go through other
statements you eventually get to a
statement you're trying to prove for
example that's a path path in
meta-mathematical space
and that's a single path a single proof
is a single path
but you can imagine there are other
proofs of the same result
there are a bundle of proofs there's
this whole set of possible proofs you
could think of as branching similar to
the quantum mechanics model that you
were talking about exactly and so and
then there's some invariants that you
can formalize in the same way that you
can for the quantum mechanical right so
the question is in in proof space you
know as you start thinking about
multiple proofs are there analogs of for
example destructive
interference of multiple proofs so
here's a bizarre idea it's just a couple
of days old so not not yet fully formed
but um as you try and do that when you
have two different proofs it's like two
photons going in different directions
you have two proofs which at an
intermediate stage are incompatible and
that's kind of like destructive
interference is it possible
for this to instruct the engineering of
automated proof systems
absolutely i mean as a practical matter
i mean the you know this whole question
in fact jonathan gorad has a nice
heuristic for automated theorem provers
that's based on our physics project that
is looking for essentially using
kind of uh using energy and in our
models energy is kind of level of
activity in this hypograph
and so there's sort of a heuristic for
automated theorem proving about how do
you pick which path to go down that uh
is based on essentially physics um and i
mean the thing that that gets
interesting about this is is the way
that one can sort of have the interplay
between like for example a black hole
what is a black hole in metal
mathematics
so the answer is what is black hole in
physics a black hole in physics is where
in the simplest form of black hole time
ends
that is all you know everything is is
crunched down to the space-time
singularity and everything just ends up
at that singularity so in our models and
that's a little hard to understand in
general relativity with continuous
mathematics and what does singularity
look like in our models it's something
very pragmatic it's just you're applying
these rules time is moving forward and
then there comes a moment where the
rules no rules apply so time stops it's
kind of like the universe dies there's
you know the nothing happens in the
universe anymore well in mathematics
that's a decidable theory that's a
theory so theories which have
undecidability which are things like
arithmetic set theory all the serious
models theories in mathematics they all
have the feature that there are proofs
of arbitrarily long length
in something like boolean algebra which
is a decidable theory there are you know
any question in boolean algebra you can
just go crunch crunch crunch and in a
known number of steps you can answer it
you know satisfiability you know might
be hard but it's still a bounded number
of steps to answer any satisfiability
problem and so that's the the notion of
a black hole in physics where time stops
that's the that's analogous to in
mathematics where there aren't infinite
length proofs where when in physics
you know you can wander around the
universe forever if you don't run into a
black hole if you run into a black hole
and time stops you're done and it's the
same thing in mathematics between
decidable decidable theories and
undecidable theories that's a that's an
example and i think we're sort of the
the attempt to understand so so another
question is kind of what is the what is
the general relativity of uh of
metamathematics what is the bulk theory
of metamathematics
so in the literature of mathematics
there are about three million theorems
that people have have published and
those represent it's kind of on this
it's like like on the earth
we would be you know uh you know we've
put cities in particular places on the
earth but yet there is ultimately you
know we know the earth is roughly
spherical and there's an underlying
space and we could just talk about you
know the world of space in terms of
where our cities happen to be but
there's actually an underlying space and
so the question is what's that for meta
mathematics and as we kind of explore
what is for example for mathematics
which is always likes taking sort of
abstract limits so an obvious abstract
limit for mathematics to take is the
limit of the future of mathematics
that is what will be you know the
ultimate structure of mathematics yeah
and one of the things that's an
empirical observation about mathematics
that's quite interesting is that a lot
of theories in one area of mathematics
algebraic geometry or something might
have they play into another area of
mathematics that that same the same kind
of a fundamental construct seemed to
occur in very different areas of
mathematics and that's structurally
captured a bit with category theory and
things like that but i think that
there's probably an understanding of
this meta-mathematical space that will
explain why different areas of
mathematics ultimately sort of map into
the same thing and i mean you know my
little challenge to myself is what's
time dilation in um uh in mata
mathematics in other words as you as you
basically as you move around in this
mathematical space of possible
statements um you know what's how does
that moving around it's basically what's
happening is that as you move around in
the space of mathematical statements
it's like you're changing from algebra
to geometry to whatever else and you're
trying to prove the same theorem but as
you try if you keep on moving to these
different places it's slower to prove
that theorem because you keep on having
to translate what you're doing back to
where you started from and that's kind
of the beginnings of the analog of time
dilation and metamathematics plus
there's probably fractional dimensions
in this space as well
oh this space is a very messy space this
space is much messier than physical
space i mean even in even in the models
of physics
physical space is is very tame compared
to branchial space and real space um i
mean the mathematical structure you know
bronchial space probably more like
hilbert space but it's a rather
complicated hilbert space
and rulial space
is more like this weird infinity
groupoid story of growth and deacon and
you know i can explain that a little bit
because in you know in in meta
mathematical space
a a path in mathematical space is a is a
a path between two statements is a way
to get by proofs
is to way to find a proof that goes from
one statement to another
and so one of the things you can do you
can think about is you've got between
statements you've got proofs and they
are paths between statements okay so now
you can go to the next level and you can
ask what about a mapping from one proof
to another
and so that's in in category theory
that's kind of a higher category the
notion of higher categories where you're
where you're mapping not just between
not just between objects but you're
mapping between the mappings between
objects and so on and so you can keep
doing that you can keep saying higher
order proofs i want mappings between
proofs between proofs and so on and that
limiting structure oh by the way one
thing that's very interesting is imagine
in proof space you've got these two
proofs
and the question is what is the topology
of proof space in other words if you
take these two parts can you
continuously deform them into each other
or is there some big hole in the middle
that prevents you from continuously
deforming them one into the other it's
kind of like you know when you when you
think about some i don't know some
puzzle for example you're moving pieces
around on some puzzle and you can think
about the space of possible states of
the puzzle and you can make this graph
that shows from one state to the puzzle
to another state of the puzzle and so on
and sometimes you can easily get from
one state to any other state but
sometimes there'll be a hole in that
space and they'll be you know you always
have to go around the circuitous route
to get from here to there there won't be
any direct way that's kind of a question
of of whether there's sort of an
obstruction in the space and so the
question is in proof space
what is the what are you know what does
it mean if there's an obstruction in
proof space yeah i don't even know what
an uh obstruction means improve space
because
for it to be an obstruction it should be
reachable some other way from some other
place
right so this is like an unreachable
part of the graph
no it's not just an unreachable part
it's a part where there are paths that
go one way there are parts that go the
other way and this question of homotopy
and mathematics is this question can you
continuously deform you know from one
path to another path or do you have to
go in a jump so to speak so okay so like
if you're going around a sphere for
example if you're going around
i don't know
a cylinder or something you can wind
around one way and you can there's no
paths where you can where you can easily
deform one path into another because
it's just sort of sitting on the same
side of the cylinder but when you've got
something that winds all the way around
a cylinder you can't continuously deform
that down to a point because it's it's
stuck wrapped around my intuition about
proof space is you should be able to
deform it i mean that because then
otherwise it doesn't even make sense
because
if the topology matters of the way you
move about the space that i don't even
know what that means well what it would
mean is that you would have one way of
doing a proof of something over here in
algebra yeah and another way of doing a
proof of something over here in geometry
and there would not be an intermediate
way to map between those proofs how
would that be possible if they start at
the same place and end the same place
well it's the same thing as
you know we've got points on a you know
if we've got paths on a cylinder now i
understand how it works in physical
space but it just doesn't it feels like
proof space shouldn't have that i okay i
mean i'm not sure i don't know we will
know very soon because we get to do some
experiments this is the great thing
about this stuff is that in fact you
know i i'm in the next few days i hope
to do a bunch of experiments on this so
you're playing with like proofs in in
this kind of space yes yes i mean so so
you know this is toy you know theories
and you know we've got good so this kind
of segues to perhaps another thing which
is this whole idea of multi-computation
so this this um
is another kind of bigger idea that so
okay this has to do with how do you make
models of things
and it's going to it's some
so
i've sort of claimed that they've been
sort of four epochs in the history of
making models of things
and um
and this multi-computation thing is is
the fourth there's a new epoch what are
the first three
the first one is is back in antiquity
ancient greek times people were like
what's the universe made of oh it's made
of you know everything is water thales
you know or everything is made of atoms
it's sort of what are things made of or
you know there are these crystal spheres
that represent where the planets are and
so on it's like a structural idea of how
the universe is constructed there's no
real notion of dynamics it's just what
is the universe how is the universe made
then we get to the 1600s and we get to
the sort of revolution of mathematics
being introduced into physics and then
we have this kind of idea of you write
down some equation
the what happens in the universe is the
solving of that equation
time enters but it's usually just a
parameter we just can you know sort of
slide it back and forth and say here's
here's where it is
okay then we come to this kind of
computational idea that i kind of
started really pushing in the in the 90
early 1980s as a result you know the
things we were talking about before
about complexity that was my motivation
but the bigger story was the story of
kind of computational models of things
and the big difference there from the
mathematical models is in mathematical
models there's an equation you solve it
you've got kind of slide time to the
place where you want it
in computational models
you give the rule and then you just say
go run the rule and time is not
something you get to slide time is
something where it just you run the rule
time goes in steps and that's how you
work out what how the system behaves you
don't time is not just a parameter time
is something that is about the running
of these of these rules and so there's
this computational irreducibility you
can't jump ahead in time but there's
still important thing is there's still
one thread of time it's still the case
you know the seller automaton state then
it has the next state and the next state
and so on the thing that is kind of was
sort of tipped off by quantum mechanics
in a sense although it it actually feeds
back even into relativity and things
like that
that there's these multiple threads of
time and so in this multi-computation
paradigm the kind of idea is instead of
there being this single threat of time
there are these kind of distributed
asynchronous threads of time that are
happening and the thing that's sort of
different there
is if you want to know what happened if
you say what happened in the system in
the case of the computational paradigm
you just say well after a thousand steps
we got this result
right but in the multi-computational
paradigm after a thousand steps not even
clear what a thousand steps means
because you've got all these different
threads of time but there is no state
there's all these different possible you
know there's all these different paths
and so the only way you can know what
happened is to have some kind of
observer who is saying here's how to
parse
the results of what was going on right
but that observer is embedded and they
don't have a complete picture so in the
case of physics that's right yes and
then in the but that's but so the idea
is that in this multi-computation setup
that it's this idea of these multiple
threads of time and models that are
based on that and this is similar to
what people think about in
non-deterministic computation so you
have a turing machine usually it has a
definite state it follows another state
follows another state but typically what
people have done when they thought about
these kinds of things is they've said
well there are all these possible paths
a non-deterministic turing machine can
follow all these possible paths but we
just want one of them we just want the
one that's the winner that factors the
number or whatever else
and similarly you know it's the same
story in logic programming and so on but
we say we've got this goal find us a
path to that goal i just want one path
then i'm happy or theorem proving same
story i just want one proof and then i'm
happy
what's happening in multi-computation in
physics
is we actually care about many parts
and well there is a case for example
probabilistic programming is a version
of multi-computation in which you're
looking at all the paths you're just
asking for probabilities of things um
but in a sense in physics we're taking
different kinds of samplings for example
in quantum mechanics we're taking a
different kind of sampling of all these
multiple paths
and but the thing that is notable is
that when you are when you're an
observer embedded in this thing etc etc
etc
with various other sort of footnotes and
so on it is inevitable
that the thing that you parse out of
this system looks like general
relativity and quantum mechanics um in
other words that just by the very
structure of this multi-computational
setup
it inevitably is the case
that you have certain
emergent laws now
why is this perhaps not surprising
in thermodynamics and statistical
mechanics there are sort of inevitable
emergent laws
of sort of gas dynamics that are
independent of the of the details of the
molecular dynamics sort of the same kind
of thing but i think what happens is
what's sort of a funny thing that i've
just been understanding very recently is
when when i kind of introduced this
whole sort of computational paradigm
complexity-ish thing back in the 80s it
was kind of like a big downer because
it's like there's a lot of stuff you
can't say about what systems will do
and then what i realized is and then you
might say now we've got
multi-computation it's even worse you
know it isn't just one thread of time
that we can't explain it's all these
threads of time we can't explain
anything
but the following thing happens
because
there is all this irreducibility and any
detailed thing you might want to answer
it's very hard to answer but when you
have an observer who has certain
characteristics like computational
boundedness sequentiality of time and so
on that observer
only samples certain aspects of this
incredible complexity going on in this
multi-computational system and that
observer is sensitive only to
some underlying core structure of this
multi-computational system there is all
this irreducible computation going on
all these details but to that kind of
observer what's important is only the
the core structure of multi-computation
which means that observer observes
comparatively simple laws and i think it
is inevitable that that observer
observes laws which are mathematically
structured like general relativity and
quantum mechanics which by the way are
the same law in our in our model of
physics so that's an explanation why
there are simple laws that explain a lot
for this observer potentially yes but
the the place where this gets really
interesting is
there are all these fields of science
where people have kind of gotten stuck
where they say we'd really love to have
a physics-like theory of economics we'd
really love to have a physics like lore
in linguistics
we gotta talk about molecular biology
here okay so what where where does
multi-computation come in for biology
economics is super interesting too but
biology okay let's talk about that so
let's talk about chemistry for a second
okay
so i mean i have to say you know this is
it's such a weird business for me
because you know
they're these kind of paradigmatic ideas
and then the actual applications and
it's like i've always said i i know
nothing about chemistry i learned all
the chemistry i know you know the night
before some exam when i was 14 years old
but yeah but i've actually learned a
bunch more chemistry and in in more from
language these days we have really
pretty nice symbolic representation of
chemistry and in understanding the
design of that i've actually i think
learned a certain amount of chemistry
though if you quizzed me on sort of
basic high school chemistry i would
probably totally fail but um uh but but
okay so what is chemistry i mean
chemistry is sort of a story of you know
chemical reactions are like you've got
this particular chemical it's
represented as some graph of you know
these are these are this configuration
of molecules with these bonds and so on
and a chemical reaction happens you've
got these sort of two graphs they
interact in some way you get another
graph or multiple other graphs out so
that's kind of the the the the sort of
the the abstract view of what's
happening in chemistry and so when you
do a chemical synthesis for example you
are given certain sort of these are
possible reactions that can happen and
you're asked can you piece together this
a sequence of such reactions a sequence
of such sort of axiomatic reactions
usually called name reactions in
chemistry can you piece together a
sequence of these reactions so that you
get out at the end this great molecule
you were trying to synthesize and so
that's a story very much like theorem
proving and people have done
actually they started in the 1960s
looking at at kind of the theorem
proving approach to that although it
didn't really it didn't it didn't uh was
sort of done too early i think um but
anyway so that's kind of the view is
that that chemistry chemical reactions
are the story of of all these different
sort of paths of possible things that go
on okay let's let's go to an even lower
level let's say instead of asking about
uh which species of molecules we're
talking about let's look at individual
molecules and let's say we're looking at
individual molecules and they are having
chemical reactions and we're building up
this big graph of all these reactions
that are happening okay so so then we've
got this big graph and by the way that
big graph is incredibly similar to these
hypergraph rewriting things um in fact
in the underlying theory of
multi-computation there are these things
we call token event graphs which are
basically you've broken your state into
tokens like in the case of a hypergraph
you've broken it into hyperedges and
each event is just consuming some number
of tokens and producing some number of
tokens yeah but then you have to there's
a lot of work to be done on update rules
in terms of what they actually are for
chemistry yeah what they are for our
observed chemistry yes indeed yes indeed
we've been working on that actually
because we have this beautiful system in
wolfram language for representing
chemistry symbolically so we actually
have you know this is a this is an
ongoing thing to actually figure out
what they are for some practical cases
does that require human injection or can
it be automatically discovered
these update rules well if we implement
chemistry better we could probably
discover them automatically but i think
in in reality right now it's like there
are these particular reactions and
really to understand what's going on
we're probably going to pick a
particular subtype of chemistry and just
because because let me explain where
this is going
the place that here's here's where this
is going so
we got this whole network of all these
molecules having all these reactions and
so on
and this is some whole
multi-computational story because each
each uh
sort of chemical reaction event is its
own separate event where we're saying
they all happen asynchronously we're not
describing in what order they happen you
know maybe that order is governed by
some quantum mechanics thing doesn't
really matter we're just saying they
happen in some order and then we ask
what is the what what's the you know how
do we think about the system well
this thing is some kind of big
multi-computational system the question
is what is the chemical observer
and one possible chemical observer is
all you care about is did you make that
particular drug molecule you're just
asking you know the for the one path
another thing you might care about is i
want to know the concentration of each
species
right i want to know you know at every
stage i'm going to solve the
differential equations that represent
the concentrations and i want to know
what those all are but there's more
because when and it's kind of like
you're going below in statistical
mechanics there's kind of all these
molecules bouncing around and you might
say
we're just going to ignore we're just
going to look at the aggregate
densities of certain kinds of molecules
but you can look at a lower level you
can look at this whole graph of possible
interactions and so the kind of the idea
would be
what you know is the only chemical
observer
one who just cares about overall
concentrations or can there be a
chemical observer who cares about this
network of what happened and so that
the question then is so let me give an
analogy so this is where i think this is
potentially very relevant to molecular
molecular biology and molecular
computing
uh when we think about a computation
usually we say it's input it's output we
you know or chemistry we say there's
this input we're going to make this
molecule as the output
but
what if what we actually encode what if
our computation whatever the thing we
care about is some part of this dynamic
network
what if it isn't just the input and the
output that we care about what if
there's some dynamics of the network
that we care about now imagine you're a
chemical observer what is a chemical
observer well in molecular biology there
are all kinds of weird sorts of
observers there are membranes that exist
that have you know different kinds of
molecules that can bind to them things
like this it's not obvious that the from
a human scale we just measure the
concentration of something is the
relevant story we can imagine that for
example when we look at this whole
network of possible reactions
we can imagine you know at a physical
level we can imagine well what was the
actual momentum direction of that of
that molecule what was it which we don't
pay any attention to when we were just
talking about chemical concentrations
what was the orientation of that
molecule these kinds of things
and so here's here's the place where i'm
i have a little suspicion okay so one of
the questions in biology is what matters
in biology
and that is you know we have all these
chemical reactions we have all these all
these molecular processes going on in
you know in biological systems what
matters
and you know one of the things is to be
able to tell what matters well so a big
story of the what mata's question was
what happened in genetics in 1953 when
dna was figured out how dna worked
because before that time you know
genetics have been all these different
effects and complicated things and then
it was realized ah there's something new
a molecule can store information which
wasn't obvious before that time a single
molecule can store information so
there's a place where there can be
something important that's happening in
molecular biology and it's just in the
sequence that's storing information in a
molecule
so the possibility now is imagine this
dynamic network this uh you know causal
graphs and multi-way causal graphs and
so on that represent all of these
different reactions between molecules
what if there is some aspect of that
that is storing information that's
relevant for molecular biology
in the dynamic aspect of that yes that's
right so that it's similar to how the
structure of a dna molecule
stores information it could be the
dynamics of the system somehow stores
information and this
kind of process might allow you to give
predictions of what that would be well
yes but also imagine that you're trying
to do
for example imagine you're trying to do
molecular computation okay you might
think the way we're going to do
molecular computation is we're just
going to run the thing we're going to
see what came out we're going to see
what molecule came out
this is saying that's not the only thing
you can do there is a different kind of
chemical observer that you can imagine
constructing which is somehow sensitive
to this dynamic network exactly how that
works how we make that measurement i
don't know but i have a few ideas but
but um that that's what's important so
to speak and that that means and by the
way you can do the same thing even for
touring machines you can say if you have
a multi-way turing machine you can say
how do you compute with a multi-way
turing machine you cut you can't say
well we've got this input and this
output because the thing has all these
threads of time and it's got lots of
outputs and so then you say well what
does it even mean to be a universal
multi-way touring machine i don't fully
know the answer to that but it has an
interesting idea freak touring out for
sure
because then uh the dynamics of the the
trajectory of the computation matters
yes yes i mean but but the thing is that
that so this is again a story of what's
the observer so to speak in chemistry
what's what's the observer there now to
give an example of of where that might
matter a very uh sort of uh present day
example is in immunology um
where you know we have whatever it is
you know 10 billion different kinds of
antibodies that are you know all these
different shapes and so on we have i'm a
trillion different kinds of t cell
receptors that we can that we produce
and you know the the traditional theory
of immunology is this clonal selection
theory where we're constantly producing
randomly producing all these different
antibodies and as soon as one of those
binds to an antigen then that one gets
amplified and we produce more of that
antibody and so on
um back in the 1960s um
immunologist called nilsiona who was the
guy who invented monoclonal antibodies
various other things um kind of had this
network theory of the immune system
where it would be like well we produce
antibodies
but then we produce antibodies to the
antibodies anti-antibodies and we
produce anti-anti-antibodies and we get
this whole dynamic network of
interactions between different immune
system cells
and that was that that was kind of a
qualitative theory at that time and it's
i've been a little disappointed because
i've been studying immunology a bit
recently and i i knew something about
this like 35 years ago or something and
i knew you know i'd read a bunch of the
books and i talked to a bunch of the
people and so on and it was like
an emerging theoretical immunology world
and then i look at the books now and
they're very thick because they've got
you know there's just a ton known about
immunology and you know all these
different pathways all these different
details and so on but the theoretical
sections seem to have shrunk
um
and so it's um so the question is
what you know for example immune memory
where is the where does the immune
memory reside is it actually some cell
sitting in our bone marrow that is you
know living for the whole of our lives
that's going to spring into action as
soon as we're shown the same antigen or
is it something different from that is
it something more dynamic is it
something more like some network of
interactions between these different
kinds of immune system cells and so on
and it's known that there are plenty of
interactions between t cells and you
know there's plenty of dynamics but what
the consequence of that dynamics is is
not clear and to have a qualitative
theory for that doesn't it doesn't seem
to exist in fact i was just just been
trying to study this so i'm quite
incomplete in my study of these things
but i was a little bit taken aback
because i i've been looking at these
things and it's like and then they get
to the end where they have the most
advanced theory that they've got and it
turns out it's a cellular automaton
theory um
it's like uh okay well at least i
understand that theory yeah um but but
uh you know i think that the possibility
is that in um
uh this is a place where if you want to
know you know explain roughly how the
immune system works it ends up being
this dynamic network and then the the
you know the immune consciousness so to
speak the observer ends up being
something that you know in the end it's
kind of like does the human get sick or
whatever but it's a it's something which
is a complicated story that relates to
this whole sort of dynamic network and
so on and i think that's another place
where this kind of notion of
where i think multi-computation has the
possibility
see one of the things okay you can end
up with something where yes there is a
general relativity in there there but it
turns up but it may turn out that the
observer who
sees general relativity in the immune
system is an observer that's irrelevant
to what we care about about the immune
system i mean it could be yes there is
some effect where you know there's some
you know time dilation of t cells
interacting with whatever but it's like
that's an effect that's just irrelevant
and the thing we actually care about is
things about you know
what happens when you have a vaccine
that goes into some place in shape space
and you know how does that affect other
places in shape space and how does that
spread you know what's the what's the
analog of the speed of light in shape
space for example that's and that's an
important issue if you have one of these
dynamic theories it's like you you know
you you poke into shape space by having
you know let's say a vaccine or
something that has a particular
configuration in shape space how how
quickly as this dynamic network spreads
out how quickly do you get sort of other
antibodies
in different places in shape space
things like that when you say shape
space you mean the shape of the
molecules or those and then so this is
like uh
it could be deeply connected to the
protein and multi-protein folding all of
that kind of stuff to be able to say
something interesting about the the
dance of proteins that right exactly
that actually has an impact on
um
helping develop drugs for example or has
an impact on
virology immunology helping too i think
the big thing is you know when we think
about molecular biology
the um uh you know what what is the
qualitative way to think about it you
know in other words is it chemical
reaction networks right is it you know
genetics you know dna
big you know big news it's kind of
there's a digital aspect to the whole
thing you know what is the qualitative
way to think about how things work in
biology um you know when we think about
i don't know some phenomenon like aging
or something which is a big complicated
phenomenon which just seems to have all
these different tentacles is it really
the case that that can be thought about
in some you know without dna when people
were describing you know genetic
phenomena
there were you know dominant recessive
this that and the other got very very
complicated and then people realized oh
it's just you know and and what is a
gene and so on and so on and so on then
people realize it's just base pairs and
there's this digital representation and
so the question is what is the
overarching representation that we can
now start to think about using a
microbiology i don't know how this will
work out and this is again one of these
things where and and the place where
that gets important is you know maybe
molecular biology is doing molecular
computing by using some dynamic process
that is something where it is very
happily saying oh i just got a result
it's in the dynamic structure of this
network now i'm going to go and do some
other thing based on that result for
example but we're like oh i don't know
what's going on you know it's just we
just measured them levels of these
chemicals and we couldn't conclude
anything but it just we're looking at
the wrong thing and and so that's the
that's kind of the the the potential
there and it's it's um i mean these
things are i don't know it's it's for me
it's it's like i've not really that was
not a view i mean i've thought about
molecular computing for ages and ages
and ages and i've always imagined that
the big story is kind of the the
original promise of nanotechnology of
like can we make a molecular scale
constructor that will just build build a
molecule in any shape but i don't think
i i'm now increasingly concluding that's
not the big point the big point is
something more dynamic that will be an
interesting end point for any of these
things but that's perhaps not the thing
you know because the one example we have
molecular computing that's really
working is us biological organisms
and you know maybe the thing that's
important there is not uh this you know
what chemicals do you make so to speak
but more this kind of dynamic process
it's a dynamic process and then you can
have a good model like the hypergraph to
to then explore
ex
what like
simulate again make predictions and if
they i think just have a way to reason
about biology i mean it's it's hard you
know but first of all biology doesn't
have theories like physics you know
physics is a much more successful sort
of global theory kind of kind of area
you know biology what are the global
theories of biology pretty much
darwinian evolution that's the only
global theory of biology you know other
any other theory is just a well the
kidneys work this way this thing works
this way and so on there isn't i suppose
another global theory is digital
information in dna that's another sort
of global fact about biology but the the
difficult thing to do is to match
something you uh have a model of in the
hyper graph to the actual like how do
you discover the theory
how do you how do you discover the
theory okay you have something that
looks nice and makes sense but like you
have to match it to validation oh sure
right and that's tricky because you're
walking around in the dark
not entirely i mean so so you know for
example in what we've been trying to
think about is take actual chemical
reactions okay so you know one of my one
of my goals is can i compute the primes
with molecules okay that's if i can do
that then i kind of maybe i can compute
things
and you know there's this nice automated
lab these guys this emerald cloud lab
people are built with wolfram language
and so on that's an actual physical lab
and you send it a piece of wolf and
language code and it goes and you know
actually does physical experiments and
so one of my one of my goals because i'm
not a test tube kind of guy i'm more of
a software kind of person is can i make
something where you know in this
automated lab we can actually get it so
that there's some gel that we made and
you know the positions of the stripes
i mean that would be that would be an
example of of where and that would be
with a particular
uh you know framework for actually doing
the molecular computing you know with
particular kinds of molecules and and
there's a lot of kind of ambient
technological mess so to speak
associated with oh is it carbon is it
this is that you know is it important
that there's a bromine atom here et
cetera et cetera et cetera this is all
chemistry that i don't know much about
um and you know that's that's a sort of
you know unfortunately that's down at
the level you know i i would like to be
at the software level not at the level
of the transistors so to speak but in
chemistry you know there's a certain
amount we have to do i think at the
level of transistors before we get up to
being able to do it although you know
automated labs certainly help in in
setting that up
i talked to
a guy named charles hoskinson
he mentioned that he's collaborating
with you
he's an interesting guy he sends me
papers on uh speaking of automated
theorem proving a lot he's exceptionally
well read on that area as well so what's
the nature of your collaboration with
him he's the creator of cardano what's
the nature of the color collaboration
between
cardano and the whole space of
blockchain and wolfram or from alpha or
from blockchain all that kind of stuff
well okay we're segueing to a
slightly different world but but um so
although not completely unconnected
right the whole thing is somehow
connected i know i mean the the you know
the strange thing in my life is i've
sort of alternated between doing basic
science and doing technology about five
times in my life so far and the thing
that's just crazy about it is you know
every time i do one of these
alternations i think there's not going
to be a way back to the other thing and
like i thought for this physics project
i thought you know we're doing
fundamental theory of physics maybe
it'll have an application in 200 years
um but now i've realized
um actually this multi-computation idea
is is applicable here and now it's and
in fact it's also giving us this way
i'll just mention one other thing and
then to talk about blockchain um the um
the question of um uh actually that
relates to several different things but
but um one of the things about about
okay so
our wolfram language which is our
attempt to kind of represent everything
in the world computationally and it's
the thing i kind of started building 40
years ago
in the form of actual wolfram language
uh 35 years ago um it's kind of this
idea of can we can we express things
about the world in computational terms
and you know we've come a long way in
being able to do that well from alpha is
kind of the consumer version of that
where you're just using natural language
as input the um and it turns it into our
symbolic language and that's you know
the symbolic language wolf and language
is what people use and have been using
for the last 33 years actually
mathematica which is its first
instantiation will be one third of a
century old in uh in october um and um
that
it's it's kind of interesting what do
you mean one third of a centuries i mean
33 or 30 what are we
in the third
33 in the third um so
but i've never heard of anyone
celebrating that anniversary but i like
it i know a third of a century though
it's it's like cannot get many many
slices of a century that are interesting
yeah but but you know i think that the
the thing that's really striking about
that is that means you know including
the whole sort of technology stack i
built around that's about 40 years old
and that means it's a significant
fraction of the total age of the
computer industry
um and it's i mean i think it's cool
that we can still run you know
mathematica version 1 programs today and
so on and and we've sort of maintained
compatibility and we've been just
building this big tower all those years
of just more and more and more
computational capabilities it's sort of
interesting we just made this this
picture um of kind of the different kind
of threads of of of computational
content of you know mathematical content
and
and you know uh all sorts of things with
you know data and graphs and whatever
else and what you see in this picture is
about the first 10 years it's kind of
like it's just a few threads
and then then about
maybe 15 20 years ago it kind of
explodes in this whole collection
different threads of all these different
capabilities that are now part of
language and representing different
things in the world but the thing that
was super lucky in some sense is it's
all based on one idea it's all based on
the idea of symbolic expressions and
transformation rules for symbolic
expressions which was kind of what i
originally put into this smp system back
in 1979 that was a predecessor of the
whole world from language stack
so that idea
was an idea that i got from sort of
trying to understand mathematical logic
and so on it was my attempt to kind of
make a general human comprehensible
model of computation of just everything
is a symbolic expression and all you do
is transform symbolic expressions
and you know in in retrospect i was very
lucky that i understood as little as i
understood then because had i understood
more i would have been completely
freaked out about all the different ways
that that kind of model can can fail
because what do you do when you have a a
a symbolic expression you make
transformations for symbolic expressions
well for example one question is there
may be many transformations that could
be made in a very multi-computational
kind of way but what we're doing is
picking we're using the first
transformation that applies and we keep
doing that until we reach a fixed point
and that's the result and that's kind of
a very
it's kind of a way of of sort of sliding
around the edge of multi-computation and
back when i was working on smp and
things i actually thought about these
questions about about how you know how
what determines the this kind of
evaluation path so for example you know
you work out fibonacci you know
fibonacci is a recursive thing f of n is
f of n minus one plus f of n minus two
and you get this whole tree of recursion
right and there's the question of how do
you evaluate that tree of recursion do
you do it sort of depth first where you
go all the way down one side do you do
it breadth first where you're kind of
collecting the terms together where you
know that you know f of a plus f of
seven f of seven plus f of six you can
collect the f of sevens and so on these
are um you know i didn't realize that at
the time it's kind of funny i was
working on on gauge field theories back
in 1979 and i was also working on the
evaluation model
in smp and they're the same problem but
it took me 40 more years to realize that
and this question about how you do this
sort of evaluation front that's a
question of reference frames it's a
question of of kind of the um the story
of i mean that that's that is basically
this question of in what order is the
universe evaluated
and that and so what you realize is
there's this whole sort of world of
different kinds of computation that you
can do sort of multi-computationally and
that's a that's an interesting thing it
has a lot of implications for
distributed computing and so on
it also has a potential implication for
blockchain which we haven't fully worked
out which is some and this is not what
we're doing with cardano but but this is
a different thing um the um this is
something where uh one of the questions
is
um when you have
in a sense blockchain is a deeply
sequentialized story of time because in
blockchain there's just one copy of the
of the ledger and you're saying this is
what happened you know time has
progressed in this way and the other
little things around the edge as as you
try and reach consensus and so on and
and uh you know actually we just
recently we've had this little
conference we organized about the the
theory of distributed consensus because
i realized that a bunch of interesting
things that some of our science can tell
one about that but that's a different
let's let's not go down that that part
yeah but distributed consensus is that
still has a sequential there's like
there's still sequentiality so just
don't tell me you're thinking through
like how to apply multi-computation to
uh blockchain yes and so so that becomes
a story of you know instead of
transactions all having to settle in one
ledger it's like a story of all these
different ledgers and they all have to
have some ultimate consistency which is
what causal and variance would give one
but it can take a while and the it can
take a while as kind of like quantum
mechanics so it's kind of what's
happening is that these different paths
of history that correspond to you know
in one part of history you got paid this
amount in another path of history you
got paid this amount in the end the
universe will always become consistent
now now the way it will it works is okay
it's a little bit more complicated than
that what happens is the way space is
knitted together in our theory of
physics is through all these events
and the the the idea is that the way
that economic space is knitted together
is between is there these autonomous
events that essentially knit together
economic space so there are all these
threads of transactions that are
happening and the question is can they
be made consistent are there is there
something forcing them to be sort of a
consistent fabric of economic reality
and sort of what this has led me to is
trying to realize how does economics
fundamentally work
and you know what is economics and uh
you know what what are the atoms of
economics right so to speak and so what
i've kind of realized is that that sort
of the
perhaps i don't even know if this is
right yet there's sort of events in
economics of transactions there are
states of agents that are kind of the
atoms of economics
and then transactions are kind of agents
transact and some
transact in some way and that's an event
and then the question is how do you knit
together sort of economic space from
that what is there an economic space
well all these transactions there's a
whole complicated collection of possible
transactions but one thing that's true
about economics is we tend to have the
notion of a definite value for things
we could imagine
that you know you buy
a cookie
from somebody and
they want to get a movie ticket
and there is some way that ai bots could
make some path
from the cookie to the movie ticket by
all these different trans intermediate
transactions
but in fact
we have an approximation to that which
is we say they each have a dollar value
and we have this kind of numeric concept
of there's just a way of kind of of of
taking this whole complicated space of
transactions and parsing it in something
which is a kind of a simplified thing
that is kind of like our parsing of
physical space
and so my my guess is that the uh yet
again i mean it's crazy that all these
things are so connected this is another
multi-computation story another story of
where what's happening is that the
economic consciousness the economic
observer is not going to deal with all
of those a different microscopic
transactions they're just going to parse
the whole thing by saying there's this
value it's a number and that's that's
their understanding of their summary of
this economic network and there will be
all kinds of things like there are all
kinds of arbitrage opportunities which
are kind of like the quantum effects in
this whole thing and um that's uh you
know and places where there's where
there's sort of different paths that can
be followed and and so on and there's so
the question is can one make a sort of
global theory of economics and then my
test case is again what is time dilation
and economics
and and i know for you know if you
imagine a very agricultural economics
where people are growing lettuces and
fields and things like this and you ask
questions about well if you're
transporting lettuces to different
places you know what is the value of the
lettuces after you have to transport
them versus if you're just sitting in
one place and selling them you can kind
of get a little bit of an analogy there
but i think there's a there's a better
and more complete analogy
and that's the question of is there a
theory like general relativity that is a
global theory of economics and is it
about something we care about it could
be that there is a global theory but
it's about a feature of economic reality
that isn't important to us now another
part of the story is can one use those
ideas to make essentially a distributed
blockchain a distributed generalization
of blockchain kind of the quantum analog
of money so to speak where where you
have for example you can have
uncertainty relations where you're
saying you know well if i if i insist on
knowing my bank account right now
there'll be some uncertainty if i'm
prepared to wait a while then it'll be
much more certain um and so there's you
know is there a way of using and so
we've made a bunch of prototypes of this
um which i'm not yet happy with because
what i realized is to really understand
these prototypes actually have to have a
foundational theory of economics and so
that's kind of a uh you know it may be
that we could deploy one of these
prototypes as a practical system but i
think it's really going to be much
better if we actually have an
understanding of how this plugs into
kind of the economics that means like a
fundamental theory of transactions
between
entities well that's that's what you
mean by economics yes i think so but i
mean you know how how there emerge sort
of laws of economics i don't even know
and i've been asking friends of mine who
are who are economists and things what
is economics you know is it an axiomatic
theory is it a theory that is a kind of
a qualitative description theory is it
you know what kind of a theory is it is
it a theory you know what kind of
thinking it's like like in in biology
and evolutionary biology for example
there's a certain there's a certain
pattern of thinking that goes on in
evolutionary biology where if you're a
you know a good evolutionary biologist
somebody says that creature has a weird
horn and they'll say well that's because
this and this and this and the selection
of this kind and that kind and that's
the story
and it's not a mathematical story it's a
story of a different type of thinking
about these things by the way
evolutionary biology is yet another
place where it looks like this
multi-computational idea can be applied
and that's where where maybe speciation
is related to things like event horizons
and there's a whole whole other kind of
world of that but because it seems like
this kind of model can be applicable in
so many aspects like at the different
levels of understanding of
our reality so it could be the biology
of the chemistry at the physics level
right the economics and you could
potentially
the thing is
it's like
okay sure at all these levels it might
rhyme it might make sense as a model the
question is can you make useful
predictions that's one of these levels
that's that's right and that's that's
really a question of you know it's a
weird situation because it's a situation
where the model
probably has definite consequences the
question is are there consequences we
care about yeah and and that's some uh
you know and so
so
in the case of in the economic case
the um
uh
we're um so you know the one one thing
is this this idea of using kind of
physics-like notions
to construct a kind of distributed
analog blockchain okay the much more
pragmatic thing is that it's a different
direction and it has to do with this
computational language that we built to
describe the world that knows about you
know different kinds of cookies and
knows about different cities and knows
about how to compute all these kinds of
things one of the things that is of
interest is if you want to run the world
you need you know with with with
contracts and laws and rules and so on
there are rules at a human level and
there are kind of um things like
and so this this gets one into the idea
of computational contracts you know
right now when we write a contract it's
a piece of legalese it's you know it's
just written in english and it's not
something that's automatically
analyzable executable whatever else it's
just
english you know back in
gottfried leibniz back in you know 1680
or whatever was like um i'm gonna you
know figure out how to use logic to
decide legal cases and so on and he had
kind of this idea of let's make a
computational language for the huma the
human law
um forget about modeling nature forgot
about natural laws what about human law
can we make kind of a computational
representation of that well i think
finally we're close to being able to do
that and one of the projects that i hope
to get to as soon as the there's a
little bit of slowing down of some of
this cambrian explosion that's happening
as a project i've been meaning to really
do for a long time which is what i'm
calling a symbolic discourse language
it's is just finishing the job of being
able to represent everything like the
conversation we're having in
computational terms and one of the use
cases for that is computational
contracts another use case is something
like the the constitution that says what
the ai's what we want the ais to do so
but this is useful so you're saying uh
so these are like you're saying
computational contracts but smart
contracts this is what's in the domain
of cryptocurrencies known as smart
contracts and so the the language you've
developed this symbolic
or seek to further develop symbolic
discourse language enables you to uh
write a contract and right so write a
contract that richly represents
some aspect of the world yeah but so so
i mean smart contracts tend to be right
now mostly about things happening on the
blockchain yes and sometimes they have
oracles in fact our wolfram alpha api is
is the main thing people use to get
information about the real world so to
speak yeah within smart contracts so
well from alpha as it stands is a really
good oracle yes whoever wants to use it
that's perhaps where the relationship
with cardano is yeah that's how we
started getting involved with
blockchains is we realized people were
using you know wolfman alpha as the
oracle for smart contract so to speak
and so that got us interested in
blockchains in general and what was
ended up happening is orphan language is
with its symbolic representation of
things is really very good at
representing
things like blockchains and so i think
we now have them we don't really know
all the comparisons but we now have a
really nice environment within wolverine
language for dealing with the sort of uh
you know for representing what happens
in blockchains for analyzing what
happens with blockchains we have a whole
effort in blockchain analytics
um and uh you know we've sort of
published some samples of how that works
but but it's you know because our
technology stack welcome language and
mathematica are very widely used in the
quant finance world there's a there's a
sort of immediate uh sort of um uh
co-evolution there of of sort of the
quant finance kind of thing and
blockchain analytics and that's um so so
it's kind of the representation of
blockchain in computational language
then ultimately it's kind of like how do
you run the world with code that is how
do you write sort of all these things
which are right now regulations and laws
and contracts and things in
computational language and kind of the
the ultimate vision is that sort of
something happens in the world and then
there's this giant domino effect of all
these computational contracts that
trigger based on the thing that happened
and there's a there's a whole story to
that and of course you know i i like to
always pay attention to the latest
things that are going on and i i really
i kind of like blockchain because it's a
it's a it's another rethinking of kind
of computation it's kind of like you
know cloud computing was a little bit of
that of sort of persistent um kind of uh
computational resources and so on and uh
you know this multi-computation is a big
rethinking of kind of what it means to
compute blockchain is another bit of
rethinking of what it means to compute
the idea that you lodge kind of these
autonomous lumps of computation out
there in the blockchain world and and
one of the things that um just sort of
uh for fun so to speak is we've been
doing a bit of stuff with nfts and we
just did some nfts on gardano and we'll
be doing some more and uh you know we
did some cellular automaton nfts on
cadance people
like quite a bit um and you know one of
the things i've realized about about
nfts is that there's kind of this notion
and we're really working on this you
know i like
recording stuff you know one of the
things that's come out of of kind of my
science i suppose is this this history
matters type type story of you know it's
not just the current state it's the
history that matters and i've kind of i
don't think this is actually realizing
maybe it's not coincidental that i'm
sort of the human who's recorded more
about themselves than anybody else and
then i end up with these science results
that say history matters which was not
those those things i didn't think those
were connected but they're at least
correlated yes yeah right so
you know this question about sort of
recording what has happened
and and having sort of a permanent
record of things one of the things
that's kind of interesting there is you
know you put up a website and it's got a
bunch of stuff on it but you know you
have to keep paying the hosting fees or
the things going to go away
but one of the things about blockchain
is kind of interesting is if you put
something on a blockchain and you pay
you know your commission to get that
thing you know put on you know mind put
on the block blockchain then then in a
sense everybody who comes after you
is you know they are motivated to keep
your thing alive because that's what
keeps the consistency of the blockchain
so in a sense with sort of the nft world
it's kind of like if you want to have
something permanent well at least for
the life of the blockchain but but even
if the blockchain goes out of
circulation so to speak there's going to
be enough value in that whole collection
of transactions that people are going to
archive the thing but that means that
you know pay once
and you're kind of you're lodged in the
blockchain forever and so we've been
kind of playing around with um a sort of
a hobby thing of of mine of of thinking
about sort of the nfts
and how you um and sort of the consumer
idea of kind of the it's the it's the
anti you know it's the opposite of the
snapchat view of the world so there's a
permanence to it this heavily
incentivized and uh
thereby you can have a
permanence of history right and that's
that's that's kind of the um now you
know so that's so that's one of the
things we've been doing with cardano and
it's kind of fun i think that that um i
mean this whole question about you know
you mentioned automated theorem proving
and blockchains and so on and as i've
thought about this kind of physics
inspired distributed blockchain
obviously they're the sort of the proof
that it works that they're no double
spends there's no whatever else
that proof becomes a very formal kind of
almost a matter of physics so to speak
um and uh you know it's been it's been
an interesting thing for the for the
practical blockchains to do kind of
actual automated film proving and i
don't think anybody's really managed it
in an interesting case yet it's a thing
that people you know aspire to but i
think it's a challenging thing because
basically the point is one of the one of
the things about proving correctness of
something is well you know people say
i've got this program and i'm going to
prove it's correct it's like what does
that mean you have to say what correct
means i mean it's it's kind of like then
you have to have another language and
people were very confused back in past
decades of you know oh we're going to
prove the correctness by representing
the program in another language which we
also don't know whether it's correct and
you know often by correctness we just
mean it can't crash or it can't scribble
on memory but but the thing is that
there's this complicated trade-off
because as soon as there's as soon as
you're really using computation you have
computational irreducibility you have
undecidability if you want to use
computation seriously you have to kind
of let go of the idea that you're going
to be able to box it in and say we're
going to have just this happen and not
anything else i mean this is a this is
an old fact i mean girdle's theorem
tries to say you know piano arithmetic
the axioms of arithmetic can you box in
the integers and say these axioms give
just the integers and nothing but the
integers go to theorem showed that
wasn't the case there's a you know you
can have all these wild weird things
that are obey the piano axioms but
aren't integers and there's this kind of
infinite hierarchy of additional axioms
you would have to add and it's kind of
the same thing you you don't get to you
know if you want to say i want to know
what happens you're boxing yourself in
and there's a limit to what can happen
so to speak so it's a it's a complicated
trade-off and it's a it's a it's a big
trade-off for ai so to speak it's kind
of like do you want to let computation
actually do what it can do or do you
want to say no it's very very boxed in
to the point where we can understand
every step and that's a that's kind of a
thing that that um that becomes
difficult to do but that that's some i
mean in in general
i would say one of the things that's
kind of complicated in my
uh sort of life in the whole sort of
story of computational language and all
this technology and science and so on i
mean i i kind of in in the flow of one's
life it's sort of interesting to see how
these things play out because i you know
i've kind of concluded that i'm in the
business of making kind of artifacts
from the future
which means you know there are things
that i've done i don't know this physics
project i don't know whether anybody
would have gotten to it for 50 years you
know the fact that mathematica is a
third of a century old and i know that a
bunch of the core ideas are not well
absorbed i mean that is people finally
got this idea that i thought was a
triviality of notebooks that was 25
years
and um you know some of these core ideas
about symbolic computation and so on are
not not absorbed i mean people people
use them every day in wolfram language
and you know do all kinds of cool things
with them but if you say what is the
fundamental intellectual point here it's
it's not well absorbed and it's it's
something where you kind of realize that
you're you're sort of building things
and i i kind of made this this thing
about you know we're building artifacts
from the future so to speak and i
mentioned that it's our uh we have a a
conference ever it's coming up actually
in a couple of weeks our annual
technology conference uh where we talk
about all the all the things we're doing
um and uh you know so i was talking
about it last year about you know we're
making artifacts from the future and i
was kind of like
i had some some version of that that was
kind of a dark and frustrated thing of
like you know i'm building things which
nobody's going to care about until long
after i'm dead so to speak but um but
but then i i realized you know people
were sort of telling me afterwards you
know that's exactly how you know we're
using wolfman language in some
particular setting in you know some
computational acts field or some
organization or whatever and it's like
people are saying oh you know what did
you manage to do you know well we know
that in principle it will be possible to
do that but we didn't know that was
possible now and it's kind of like
that's the that's sort of the business
we're in and in a sense with some of
these ideas in science um you know i
feel a little bit the same way that
there are some of these things where you
know some some things like for example
this whole idea well so so to to relate
to another sort of piece of history in
the future one of you know i mentioned
we mentioned at the beginning kind of
complexity as this thing that i was
interested in back 40 years ago and so
on where does complexity come from well
i think we kind of nailed that the
answer is in the computational universe
even simple programs make it and that's
kind of the secret that nature has that
allows you to make it so so that's kind
of the um uh that that's that part but
the bigger picture there was this idea
of this kind of computational paradigm
the idea that you could go beyond
mathematical equations which have been
sort of the primary modeling medium for
300 years
and so it was like look it is inexorably
the case that people will use programs
rather than just equations and you know
i was saying that in the 1980s and
people were you know i published my big
book new kind of science that'll be 20
years ago uh next year so in 2002 and
people are saying oh no this can't
possibly be true you know we know for
300 years we've been doing all this
stuff right
to be fair
i now realize on a little bit more
analysis of what people actually said
in pretty much every field other than
physics
people said oh these are new models
that's pretty interesting in physics
people were like we've got our physics
models we're very happy with them yeah
in physics there's more resistance
because of the attachment and the power
of the equations right the idea that
programs might be the right way to
approach
right uh this field was uh there's some
resistance and like you're saying
it takes time for somebody who likes the
idea of time dilation and all these
applications i thought you would
understand this yeah right but but you
know and computational introduceability
yes exactly but but i mean it is really
interesting that just 20 years
a span of 20 years it's gone from you
know pitchforks and horror
to
yeah we get it and um you know it's
helped
that we've you know in our current
effort in fundamental physics we've
gotten a lot further and we've managed
to
put a lot of puzzle pieces together that
that makes sense but the thing that i've
been thinking about recently is this
field of complexity so i i've kind of
was a sort of a a field builder back in
the 1980s i was kind of like okay you
know can we uh you know i i'd understood
this point that there was this sort of
fundamental phenomenon of complexity and
showed up in lots of places
and i was like this is an interesting
sort of field of science and i was uh
recently
was reminded i was at this the very
first sort of get-together of what
became the santa fe institute and i was
like in fact there's even an audio
recording of me sort of saying people
have been talking about oh what should
this play you know outfit do and i was
saying well there is this thing that
i've been thinking about it's this kind
of idea of complexity nice and um it's
kind of like
and that's that's what that ended up you
implanted the seat of complexity to
santa fe that's beautiful it's a
beautiful vision but but i mean so that
but what's happened then is this idea of
complexity and you know ken you know and
i started the first research center at
university of illinois for doing that in
the first journal complex systems and so
on and uh and it's kind of an
interesting thing in in my life at least
that it's kind of like you plant this
seed you have this idea it's a kind of a
science idea you have this idea of sort
of focusing on the phenomenon of
complexity the deeper idea was this
computational paradigm but the the
nominal idea is this kind of idea of
complexity okay then you roll time
forward 30 years or whatever 35 years
whatever it is um and you say what
happened okay well now there are a
thousand complexity institutes around
the world um i think more or less we've
been trying to count them um and uh you
know there are 40 complexity journals i
think um and so
it's kind of like what actually happened
in this field right and and i look at a
lot of what happened and i'm like
uh you know i have to admit to some eye
rolling so to speak because it's kind of
like like what is what what's what
what's actually going on well what
people definitely got
was this idea of computational models
and then they got but they thought one
of the one of the kind of cognitive
mistakes i think is they say we've got a
computational model
and it
and we're looking at a system that's
complex
and our computational model gives
complexity by goalie that must mean it's
right
and unfortunately because complexity is
a generic phenomenon and computational
irreducibility is a
generic phenomenon that actually tells
you nothing
and so then the question is well what
can you do you know there's a a lot of
things that have been sort of done under
this banner of complexity and i think
it's been very successful in providing
sort of an interdisciplinary way of
connecting different fields together
which is powerful in itself right i mean
that's a biology in economics and yeah
it is right and it's a good organizing
principle but but in the end a lot of
that is around this kind of
computational paradigm computational
modeling that's the raw material that
powers that kind of uh that kind of
correspondence i think and the question
is sort of what is the you know i was
just thinking recently you know we've
been i mean the the other we've been
we've been
for years people told me you should
start some will from institute that does
basic science you know all i have is a
company that that builds software and we
you know we have a little piece that
does basic science as kind of a hobby
people are saying you should start this
wolfram institute thing and and i've
been you know because i've known about
lots of institutes and i've seen kind of
that flow of money and and kind of you
know what happens in different
situations and so on so i've been kind
of reluctant but uh but i've i've i have
realized that you know what we've done
with our company over the last 35 years
you know we built a very good machine
for doing r d
and you know innovating and creating
things and i just applied that machine
to the physics project that's how we did
the physics project in a fairly short
amount of time with a you know efficient
machine with you know various people
involved and so on um and so you know it
it works for basic science and it's like
we can do more of this
and so biology and chemistry so it's
it's become an institute yes well it
needs to become an institution an
official institute right right but the
the thing that so i was thinking about
okay so what do we do with complexity
you know what what there are all these
people who've you know what what should
happen to that field yeah and what i
realized is there's kind of this area of
foundations of complexity that's about
these questions about simple programs
what they do that's far away from a
bunch of the detailed applications the
people well it's not far away it's it's
the it's the under you know the bedrock
underneath those applications so i
realized recently this is my a recent
kind of little uh innovation of a sort
um a post that i'll do very soon
um about um
uh kind of you know the foundations of
complexity what really are they i think
they're really two ideas two conceptual
ideas that i hadn't really enunciated i
think before one is what i call
meta-modeling the other is ruleology
so what is meta modeling so metamodeling
is you've got this complicated model and
it's a model of you know hedgehogs
interacting with this interacting with
that
and the question is what's really
underneath that what is it you know is
it a turing machine is it a cellular
automaton you know what is the
underlying stuff underneath that model
and so there's this kind of meta science
question of given these models what is
the core model and i realized i mean to
me that's sort of an obvious question
but then i realized i've been doing
language design for 40 years and
language design is exactly that question
you know underneath all of this detailed
stuff people do what are the underlying
primitives and that's a question people
haven't tended to ask about models they
say well we've got this nice model for
this and that and the other what's
really underneath it and what you know
because once you have the thing that's
underneath it well for example this
multi-computation idea is an ultimate
meta modeling idea because it's saying
underneath all these fields is one kind
of paradigmatic structure and you know
you can you can imagine the same kind of
thing much more sort of uh
much sort of shallower levels in in um
in different kinds of modeling so this
the first activity is this kind of meta
modeling the the kind of the the models
about models so to speak you know what
is the what's what's you know drilling
down into models that's one thing the
other thing is this this thing that i
think we're going to call ruleology
which is kind of the
okay you've got these simple rules
you've got cellular automata you've got
turing machines you've got substitution
systems you've got registered machines
got all these different things what do
they actually do in the wild and this is
an area that i've spent a lot of time
you know working on it's a lot of stuff
in my new kind of science book is about
this um you know this new book i wrote
about combinators is is full of stuff
like this
and and this journal complex systems has
lots of papers about these kinds of
things but but there isn't really a home
for people who do
or whatever
as you call the basic science of rules
yes
yes right so it's it's like you've got
some what is it is it mathematics no it
isn't really like mathematics in fact
from my now understanding of meta
mathematics i understand that it's the
molecular dynamics level it's not the
level that mathematicians have
traditionally cared about it's not
computer science because computer
science is about writing programs that
do things you know that were for a
purpose not programs in the wild so to
speak it's not physics it doesn't have
anything to do with you know maybe
underneath some physics but it's not
physics as such so it just hasn't had a
home and if you look at you know but
what's great about it is
it's a surviving field so to speak it's
something where you know one of the
things i i find sort of inspiring about
mathematics for example is you look at
mathematics that was done you know in
ancient greece ancient you know babylon
egypt and so on it's still here today
you know you find an icosahedron that
somebody made in ancient egypt you look
at it oh that's a very modern thing it's
an icosahedron you know it's it's a
timeless kind of kind of activity and
this idea of studying simple rules and
what they do it's a timeless activity
and i can see that over the last 40
years or so as you know
even with cellular automata it's kind of
like you know you can sort of catalogue
what what are the different cellular
autonomics are used for and you know
like the the simplest rules like like
one you might even know this one rule
184 it's um rule 184 is a minimal model
for road traffic flow and you know it's
also a minimal model for various other
things but it's kind of fun that you can
literally say you know rule 90 is a
minimal model for this and this and this
rule 4 is a minimal model for this and
it's kind of remarkable that you can
just by in this raw level of this kind
of study of rules they then branch
they're the raw material that you can
use to make models of different things
so it's a it's a very pure basic science
but it's one that you know people have
explored it but they've been kind of a
little bit in the wilderness and i think
you know one of the things that i would
like to do finally is is uh you know i
always thought that sort of this notion
of pure and chaos pure and nks being the
acronym for my book new kind of science
um was um
was something that people should be
doing and you know we tried to figure
out what's the right institutional
structure to do this stuff you know we
we dealt with a bunch of universities oh
you know can we do this here well what
department would it be in it well it
isn't in a department it's it's its own
new kind of thing that's why that's why
the book was called the new kind of
science um it's kind of the the because
that's an increasingly good description
of what it is so to speak we're actually
we were thinking about kind of the
ruleological society because we're
realizing that it's kind of
it's it's some you know there's a
there's it's very it's very interesting
i mean i've never really done something
like this before because there's this
whole group of researchers who are
who've been doing things that are really
in some cases very elegant very
surviving very solid you know here's
this thing that happens in this very
abstract system but it's like
it's like what is that part of you know
it's it doesn't have a a home and i
think that's something i you know i kind
of fault myself for not having been more
you know when complexity was developing
in the 80s i didn't understand the the
the danger of applications that is it's
really cool that you can apply this to
economics and you can apply it to
evolutionary biology and this and that
and the other but what happens with
applications is everything gets sucked
into the applications and the pure stuff
it's like the pure mathematics there
isn't any pure mathematics so to speak
it's all just applications of
mathematics and i i failed to kind of
make sure that this kind of pure area
was was kind of um maintained and and
and developed and i think now you know
one of the things i i want to try to do
and and you know it's a funny thing
because i'm used to look i've been a a
tech ceo for more than half my life now
so you know this is what i know how to
do and um you know i can i can make
stuff happen and get projects to happen
even as it turns out basic science
projects in that kind of setting and and
how that translates into kind of
you know there are a lot of people
working on for example our physics
project sort of distributed through the
academic world and that's working just
great but the question is you know can
we have a sort of accelerator mechanism
that makes use of kind of what we've
learned in in sort of r d innovation and
you know but on the other hand it's a
funny thing because
you know in a company in the end the
thing is you know it's a company it
makes products that sell things sells
things to people um in you know when
you're doing basic research one of the
challenges is there isn't that same kind
of of sort of mechanism and so it's it's
it's you know how do you drive the thing
in a in a kind of a led kind of way so
that it really can can make forward
progress rather than you know what can
often happen in you know in in academic
settings where it's like well there are
all these flowers blooming but it's not
clear that they're you know that it's
that yeah they have a central mission
and a drive just like you do with the
company that's delivering a big
overarching product and that's that's uh
but the the challenges you know when you
have a the the the economics of the
world are such that you know when you're
delivering a product and people say well
that's useful we'll buy it
and then that kind of feeds back and
okay then you can then you can pay the
people who build it to eat you know so
they can eat and so on and with basic
science the the payoff
is very much less visible and and you
know with this physics project as i say
the big surprise has been that i mean
you know
for example well the big surprise with
the physics project is that it's looks
like it has near-term applications and i
was like i'm guessing this is 200 years
away
it's um i was kind of using the analogy
of of you know newton
uh starting a satellite launch company
which would have been kind of wrong time
um and uh you know but but it turns out
that's not the case but but we can't
guarantee that and if you say we're
signing up to do basic research basic
radiology let's say
and you know and we can't we don't know
the horizon you know it's it's an
unknown horizon it's kind of like an
undecidable kind of proposition of when
is this proof going to end so to speak
when is it going to be something that
that
that gets applied
i i hope this is this becomes a vibrant
new field of radiology i love it like i
told you many many times it's one of
the most amazing ideas that has been
brought to this world so i hope you
get a bunch of people to explore this
world
thank you once again for spending your
really valuable time with me today fun
stuff thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with stephen wolfram to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from richard feynman
nature uses only the longest threads to
weave her patterns
so each small piece of our fabric
reveals the organization of the entire
tapestry
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you